[Music]
so
jonathan
[Music]
so
yes sir here you hear me and all that
good stuff
might check might check what's going on
realm
what's going on y'all talk to me talk to
me six slayer what's up
victor alex thing what's going on busy
to build area
squirrelly dead i see you no that's good
let me know how my levels is good
fun show today let me know how that's
going yeah trusty nice king gonna do the
chip of death
we're gonna watch what you gotta say to
the end of the show the floyd thank you
for that brother thank you thank you
you know what i'm saying lucious
augustus what's going on
jason jones you got the bucks all right
you got that tom brady what's going
on t hatred whether b what's going on
rob c thank you brother thank you thank
you so much work on a sunday okay okay
you go listen to this in your cubicle
okay okay my man's sick
[Music]
um king is ready you know what i'm
saying saul is going to be coming
through pulling up we got a fun show
these topics is lit
i'm excited i got a new hat
it's lit yeah what's that new jerk you
got
that's fire i like that you got the
shape
oh you're going out tonight
i didn't go with that nah you should
have put the
logo with fire you should have left it
um
i just i don't know where my iop ones
are in the world oh okay so you try to
keep it on the brain you don't want to
wear nothing else it's not the brand
yeah all right no doubt i respect oh man
yo thank you the first one ksi
salute um nyt music brother thank you
super chat hype definitely hype so we
don't get the wrong he said my mic is a
little louder than attic
okay okay let me check okay normally
they'd be like yo
you're too low addy turn your mic up a
little bit
okay i think they kill you a little bit
[Music]
hello can you guys hear me am i there
[Laughter]
i'm secretly in your conscience no no no
no all right
dizzy got something for me let's see
what's going on
oh yeah yeah yeah i i did the update i
tried to update it again thank you for
that though i don't know why twitch is
doing that
but i'll take care of that on the back
and sadly
all right we're gonna get ready for
these uh guys to come in
and then we will be back in a big show
so we have some fun
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable
i know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beating they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal i got
it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be a dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dogs thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
with messaging people on aim check my
vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
[Music]
um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started
i am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people on aim check my vocals
follow on twitter but i'm anti-social
[Music]
hold you i ain't here to boy you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for attic if i can
imagine it's cool to get you some advice
and invite your girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be meto
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can never still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible other than
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Laughter]
all right here you hear ye
and we are live welcome to the iron
lords podcast and the lords of
gaming.net
episode number 192 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got bethesda's indiana jones
game
a new star wars game from ubisoft cd
projekt red's recent apology
and gamestop shares to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose passion
for gaming and consistency as a content
creator
has truly been remarkable to watch
whether it be his trademark top tens
or spicy takes on the industry all done
from a hardcore gaming perspective
introducing the creating host of the
dreamcast guy youtube channel
and a panelist on the spawncast
the owner of the funniest profile pic on
twitter
who always reminds us to keep dreaming
live from texas and making his return
into the realm
of the lords my man lord dreamcast guy
how you doing sir
pretty good happy to be back we've been
trying to do this forever there's been
so many times we all said
great topics and i've tried to be here i
finally had a sunday off i
appreciate the invite guys really happy
to be back so it's good to have you back
man i always appreciate you love what
you're doing out there man wow
you've been since you haven't been back
on in a while but you've grown like
tremendously 20k
now you're moving out here man yeah
hopefully we'll see if i get
250 or 300k this year i'll be i'll be
happy we'll see
see if the games keep popping off games
keep coming out
i'll be happy with the camera i'll be
happy with three at this point let's go
i'm super addicted to risk of rain right
now i'm so
into it uh it's a third-person shooter
roguelike
so it's one of those games where you
start out you pick a class that'll have
like a shotgun or
a sword instead of a gun or something
and then as you're playing through it
there'll be random enemies random bosses
they'll have random strengths and
weaknesses and then you get random
strength so you'll get like
more range to your attacks faster attack
speed hitting enemies will heal you
or things like killing an enemy they
explode or set off a molotov cocktail so
these roguelikes i'm so addicted to like
every time you play it it feels like an
hour-long completely new game
built for you i am so this is like my
favorite genre right now i'm so into
them
i feel like the roguelikes like i i do
feel like they're starting to
overstaturize the
the market but like it's it's different
than it was with like the battle royale
because
the majority of these are good yeah
exactly yeah
and you know sovereign put me on to it i
i gotta say dead cells started off my
addiction yes
and it turned into something crazy when
i get
neon abyss and it's just you know
steamrolled straight from there so i'm
more apt to give a roguelike uh a look
opposed to just you know like glossing
over it so i'll definitely just
they're all so different they're all
different i mean when you look at
dead cells right and then you look at
what hades did and then you
even look at returnal like maternal is
kind of it's gonna be in the same vein
and it's something totally different so
it is one of those genres that seems to
meld very well with different art styles
so it doesn't feel like it's like it's
like addicts said there's a lot of them
but i don't feel this oversaturated
because they all seem so
different star renegades like i
don't know like yeah that that
they got me with that one because there
isn't a lot of
turn base yeah you know games like that
and when i saw that i i remember king
brought it up because i i saw it on the
pc was i just wait for it to be on call
so
because at this point i you know i'm
still very on my i ain't messing with pc
right now
but at that time i was definitely ain't
messing with pcs
and then when it showed up on xbox like
i think i put like night night
hours
good day g cash got back in the realm
big show so we are going to move on
and of course we have a lord who is not
only a solid friends of the rome but
with his analysis on gaming politics and
pop culture
is highly regarded as one of the
greatest yet balanced legal minds within
our entire
gaming community introducing
the attorney and creator of the hoglar
youtube channel and
business law firm the lord of virtual
legality
who proves reasonable minds can differ
especially with his opinions on jedi
fallen order
and mass effects 2 place in history
[Laughter]
i saw your video don't you start
the university of michigan's own and
making his return into the realm of the
lords
my man lord richard hogg how you doing
sir
i'm doing great i'm doing great i love
your intros i still do uh
it's been uh it's been too long i
haven't been on in a couple months i
haven't
heard anybody disparage my mass effect
here you go hogue total respect
uh hats off to you sir hats off to you
sir
why the knees for the bet that i lost
what was it playstation 5. i don't even
know the better seller
here you go you got both knees they're
yours all right so there you go
so now what i'm going to do is the next
time we ever bend the knee
it doesn't matter who wins i'm clipping
that and saying that was you to me
salute to hope for being gracious yeah
he was nice he didn't even remember i
did
that's what was coming on this weekend i
said get the knees ready
i mean i might have remembered no
i was i wasn't gonna bring it up or
anything like that you know
oh no it's a pleasure to be back
absolutely absolutely do a favorable
turn you'll level up just a little bit
and um
what you call uh solve if we get the
super chat before we get in sure
so we have first off we got uh
michael aka best size finance with the
two dollar super chat good morning lords
hopeful as well likewise to you sir
and we have squirrely dan with the five
dollar super chat what's good
realm watch king sweat like a like a
hooker in church i got
five one wow
after today's squirrely you will have to
pay to be inside my chats
good afternoon absolute salute oh you
all caught up
yes back to home real quick yes
love seeing the growth man i love how
you're expanding you've been killing it
with the video and you've been killing
it on all fronts
love the merch by the way i got me a
nice little shirt so uh
first of all congratulations on that and
a success and then also what you've been
playing
ah absolutely no you know i haven't been
playing a ton of video games we've been
doing some backlog stuff
uh we going through death stranding a
little bit playing some more immortals
um which was one of my top games of last
year um
and definitely the best game released in
december last year
okay that's that was a shot i was the
best that was the shot i missed
what day came out did something damn
what's the shot he did i don't know it
was some other game that was like
14 episodes of virtually get out of here
oh
yeah i know what you're talking about
that other game yes yes but no i've
mostly been uh teaching my uh my oldest
uh
board games getting into an age where
she's really enjoying rule sets and
strategy and things like that so we've
been working through
um primarily cooperative games after
this podcast i've got a set
up of pandemic legacy ready to go in the
kitchen uh so we're gonna play that nice
um i've been getting people into marvel
champions the card game
uh playing as the the heroes that people
like i'm scared of that game i want to
get it but i have like a
highlighted addiction to car games
especially the marvel cinematic universe
uh
one of my favorite marvel champions one
of my favorite uh card games in a long
time oh i got to stay away i know it's
oh man you're not trying to take money
out of your bank account bro it's bad
it's really really good between
transformers
olga's in that whole where you want more
people to join you
but these are these are physical card
games or digital cards no digital
digital okay
yeah no no well i mean marvel champions
is a physical car game oh okay
wait you're talking about okay i thought
you was talking about the one on the
phone me too no i'm talking about
uh fantasy flight games card game
everybody gets a hero
spider-man iron man hawkeye whoever have
a villain that you fight
it's a modular deck you talk about rogue
lights and things so it gets
changed up every game you put that
together and then your heroes have
synergies and you try to play through it
and if you're anything like the hogue
family you lose 90
of the time uh and then i try to
convince the people in my household that
that's part of the fun
[Laughter]
you dominated you got to have that
challenge no it's cooperative i'm not i
we all lose together
[Laughter]
gymnastics of a lawyer i love the
victory that means that it's his fault
that they lost but we're a team
my wife was carrying me yesterday uh
with iron man my doctor strange was
sitting there
i don't know what he was doing holding
up the finger one i don't know
absolutely so let's get the super chat
keep it moving uh we got
hustle and motivate with the three
dollars just a chat uh keep up with the
great work iop no doubt thank you sir
appreciate it appreciate it and we got
family 108 dragons tv with the 5
super chat good afternoon lords and
guests always great to start my
afternoon with the fam
work hard play harder fast let's say
something lemon
lemon you called me yesterday i text you
back and it's delicious
again you already know what i'm waiting
to build what else we got
yeah we have gaming forte with the five
dollar super chat today is a joyous
occasion everyone pray for king's third
oh
yo i wish you the best brother today the
lord has shined on us all remember your
milk bro
yeah oh don't drink milk so you'll
definitely figure something else out let
me shout out rob c who just copped that
wall attached he put that iron log flag
in the wall oh i missed you
i like that man your boy got the flag
and we have smitty smith with the five
dollar super chat hang in there lord
king i never want to see you suffer
unlike these other heathens
thank you brother that triple you're not
definitely you're definitely on your own
there yeah yeah he even put out the book
expo yeah yeah this is new scripture for
the book of acts the chip will not take
you down
there we have aaron summers with the
five pound super chat salute to your
favorite podcasters podcast
love the positivity great guest great
banter great way to spend a sunday
hit the like and share thank you sir
appreciate it i appreciate your service
man a lot of fun stuff going on today
and you already know
we got the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table
with time sensitive because we got two
guests intros
time sensitive bye close with the girls
my brother another mother the difficult
game conqueror lord of his own world
and the heart of the young wolf my man
lord addict how we doing sir you know if
you listen to my intro
it really seems like i'm a selfish
a-hole like
you just just just listen and take that
in
and you know what i'm a hundred percent
okay exactly
you know what i was about to say look i
told you i'm the mayor of the ad
world you guys ain't invited it
literally says i don't care what the
podcast
is i just that is literally your moniker
so you got to read that one from 108
dragons all right get one
we got 108 dragons at the five dollar
super chat shout out to king calling at
4 a.m
this is the vampire podcast most of
y'all work at night right
right yeah yeah you know you was going
to get that phone call for
8 a.m because that's the time i'm up
yeah that's no that's normal
then we have drunken ninja with the five
dollars super chat happy sunday y'all
shout out to the destiny clan for
holding all down and running through
these races
don't worry today after the show we're
done with the shout out
absolutely if you could we go no i'm
going this way
your well-being sir i could use it right
too but we won't go into that all right
so um have you ever gotten that weapon
yet nope not me no no no
no no but we don't talk about that
though because people in this community
no no you ain't typing this people in
this community
they like tagging me every time one of
their friends get one stitch back from
dead yeah they're messy they're messy
yeah i just beat um nice
yeah it was it was a good game man like
i still
i think zelda because it's zelda is a
better game
but like what they didn't do in zelda
they did immortals like the temples
immortals is like crazy good
that's all i want from you know breath
of the wild too is more of
a a temple centric and not just we can
go everywhere
climb every rock time it's too much
breath of the wild slander
oh
for the single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and patriarch of the
iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
i'm doing well what's going on guys
chilling chilling i'm pretty good
smoking what's going on in the ufc last
night you saw
no i saw nothing oh i saw a domination i
missed
i missed it all so i i will defer to you
guys on that um
yo he dominated so hard that he said
next week if somebody falls out i'll
fight
yeah he was he was talking to the
commentary it was it was great max
holloway
it's crazy yeah he is he is i'm glad
that he's back and he i know he had some
issues with making weight for a bit and
yeah i'm glad that he's back played
anything uh
the only thing i got to play a little
bit of is kind of because of my
excitement for hitman three so i went
back into hitman
um man that that game is so much fun i
like it's the essence of you this this
this this has nothing to do with you
hope but
i blew up a lawyer yesterday with uh
he had to put a disclaimer i wouldn't
disclose i blew up a lawyer with a
rubber duck
and it was glorious like it was good
i hit him with a rubber duck and he flew
over like a legend yeah it was nice
i love where you are right now i'm a
puncher yeah i know man i can't
i can't go anywhere so i might as well
you know like mentally put myself
you got the ufc shirt is he on island
he's fighting uh a mega bran
the hitman 3 comes out the 20th so yeah
i'm telling you man that that i love
that murder sandbox
there's so much foolishness you can do
it's just i love it i love it i'm
excited for three getting this murky
murder on and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues demands nothing
less than that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved and soon to be the one chip
challenge lord king
i am doing fantastic thank everybody
that came out yesterday on dolph castlex
uh my live unboxing saturdays is a thing
you know fridays is the show that we do
9 p.m you know subscribe
follow and live unboxing saturdays so
you saw the big ticket item last
uh yesterday was this iron studio
jesus he is immense i could not have red
hulk be the biggest hawk in my house
i made a phone call to my man christian
christian came through
he made sure that i got exactly what i
needed to dwarf
little man over there so that's
humongous series x
that that's how i look when they be
hitting me with those ice grenades on
destiny
110 pounds something like that the boxes
all together was like 150 pounds
something crazy yesterday so it was a
great great unboxing
box uh i think it was 10 statues
yesterday at the thundercats lineup uh
everybody cool uh iron man uh wolverine
which is uh down at the bottom over
there and uh iron patriot which is up
for sale that mario is standing on
guardian right now
okay so you know that statue was up for
400 dollars at the buy sell trade group
um what i've been playing you're playing
destiny did my rage this week i got one
more raid to do and i'm gonna do all the
old rage yeah we talked about yeah we
got to get to the right we got to do all
the old
quick before we king
stop playing around with me you're
getting on my nerves we all use this
i'll have to literally tell people like
look if you about to die
pop your super i'd rather you lose your
super then restart this whole encounter
it's about time in there it's about fun
all right also i've been playing in jedi
falling order i'm in the mix right now
uh this weekend on xbox free weekend or
free
week or whatever i'm playing squadrons
it's more than i thought it was
it's like a flight slim yeah and each
like ship has their own quirks and stuff
like that because tie fighters don't
have any shielding
and you have to be more maneuverable it
turns you into a better pilot than if
you're playing
uh with the rebels because they have
shielding so you can take a hit or
whatever
but this it's so crazy i finished
odyssey
now i'm pretty sure a lot of people
finish odyssey if you're playing odyssey
you don't want to hear the ending close
your ears right you mean
uh no odyssey didn't come out they got
the patch for that
it didn't come out yet all right so when
that when that patch comes out it came
out
but anyway um i played odyssey i ended
odyssey and the first ending that i got
i wasn't satisfied with it right
so i was like oh man are you serious how
this was gonna go down and my mom's just
gonna disown me
you know because i kicked i kicked her
off the roof jesus oh
wow you went that route yeah i kicked
you off because spoilers y'all
that first time i tried to save uh you
know she disrespected me and locked me
up and took my clothes off so
i was i was highly pissed off so i
kicked off the mountain
so my mom just owned me she said you
said you was gonna bring her back all
right
so i went back and i did what y'all said
i saved before the last encounter right
nice
all right so i'm able to go back in so i
go back in and i still lose both of them
to hell with this game
it's still a sad ending i'm sitting
there with a tear in my eye my son is
sitting there like daddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
i know i'm pulling time on myself but
that's what i've been playing i have
other stuff but game pass is it do you
know what's funny that's like the
mentality i always have with xcom
you try to do a really difficult
scenario and you can't get through
without lit without at least losing one
or two people and you get so annoyed
that's good enough let's just go let's
go that's it no
we have lord of empires death singing
with the five pound super chat salute to
the lords and guests
all love in the realm what weapon could
that be because i may have it
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito spread
that
into roman iop not telling you what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
salute to games
gaming times gaming times patrick with
the five dollar super chat keep up the
great works at iop
salute you already know last word with
ebantus was lit
my man the irl titan he was in the
building man yo
super fun if you enter your bodybuilding
your fitness is a gamer he's cool he's
hilarious
we talked about what's going on in the
state of the game check that out it's on
ireland podcast
on youtube and then um yeah man i've
been raiding with my brothers you
already know did we tell the people that
don't know that today is the hot chip
challenge day yes we did
i have promoted it and no no i'm talking
about like the people that's there
because i didn't say during my segment
i'm sorry oh you don't go for it
um yeah um okay so squirrely dan
the snitch got me to take this hot chip
challenge so after we finish with the
show
yeah so you're gonna have to stick
through to the end yes and you know if i
guess want to sit around and watch me
sweat
and almost die uh
all right and i don't drink milk so it
might be even funnier
than what y'all are you're going to try
to do the five minute thing
oh yeah definitely the chip challenge so
i want everybody to set they uh they
watched
it
make sure you handle it with gloves oh
yeah yeah you saw the gloves right here
yeah you don't want you don't want that
touching anything else but accidentally
yeah
i'm mistaken oh my god oh okay lord stay
tuned to the
end of the show because that is what it
is if you don't like me
for all you do putting them down um them
thumbs down and
check both youtube dudes and other dudes
that's on the fence right now y'all
didn't check in right now
if you want to see me sweat and almost
die yeah today is your day you might
turn it pretty much
the entire tcl community constituted
because they don't like the community
manager up here man
sorry guys sorry sub super chat finish
yeah no doubt um
the living flame with the five dollar
super chat hear ye hear ye the medium is
in 11 days yes
finally an interesting horror game after
such a long drought
happy sunday lords i'm praying for yes
yes we all are thank you
hello and there we have squirrely dad
with the two super chat we hurt you cuz
we love you kids that's why
that's why you always get those
protections
i need to order protection oh can we get
orders of protection from you
is that possible from hogan
[Laughter]
sorry i don't handle that service
yo i have someone i can refer you to
thank you you know a guy that knows a
guy
do it again boys have a chat so yeah we
have web head 420 with the 10
super chat happy sunday to the lords and
guests this is the most uplifting
podcast on the web
please keep up the positivity ps king
slanders tcl so much i had to upgrade my
tv to samsung
well done sir those have tcl's in the
bushes
okay we have black black ronin with the
five dollars
you better have milk on hand i did that
challenge and it's no joke
one bite chew and swallow best route
king
paws
you know what the worst part is king
like when you first take it for like 30
seconds
this ain't nothing what did we just see
yeah we're gonna figure it out
we're gonna see if we look man so that's
all right that for big for me
what you call it uh parallel guard guy
did all the endings from out of worlds
on that great dlc um hellblade finally
got it down on my backlog i
started on playstation probably not
finished it and then i said you know
what let me just start over on series x
and just run
it through tremendous tremendous i have
to give it up dizzy's in the chat
you'll be proud yeah like them with a
small budget what they were able to do
transformative um the way they got a
psychological horror was amazing
illusions my only nitpick i felt the
puzzles overstayed they welcome a little
bit too long
you know what i'm saying but um the game
is tremendous like i cannot wait to see
them with about them with a budget it's
going to be
yeah it's going to be crazy get big
cloud then we move on we have a big
cloud with the five dollar super chat
get my boy king david the heart-shaped
erb yeah
wakanda forever hit that like button big
classic little playstation nation in the
building two announcements real quick
yo everybody man the nintendo guru bobby
we've had him on iop before
he's going through he just went through
some covet uh situation
and his health and medical bills so
please i'm going to put the link in the
chat man if you want to donate anything
good guy community loves him yeah you
know what i'm saying so please he's been
suffering through it
um that's i'll put the link in there if
you want to donate to his family and
stuff again
the bills are really piling up he has
some shout out to everyone who's donated
because uh they they set up they set a
goal and they and i mean the community
blew by
blue box yeah just yeah anyone said just
want to just say your love
nintendo girl bobby's a good guy so
salute to him also hit up lord clowns
y'all he's going through it too man hit
up lord clowns check on him see how he's
doing
you know a lot of our friends in the
community you know these are gaming
brothers please check on them make sure
they're okay
and then let me see oh alex said psx
fighter
i saw a kid smoove do this challenge be
careful sad face okay
we got it so look real quick this is a
quick thing for hulk
and dreamcast guy because both of you
have not been on in so long and i need
this answer real quick before you get
the topics
which is top fives i never got your top
five video games or franchises of all
time dreamcast guy
ooh me okay then i'd say this will be
one of them
yeah final fantasy number one resident
evil number two
look grandia is number three legend of
zelda
as number four what's up what's up here
we go
i think a lot of zelda i think i like a
lot of zeldas in a lot of different ways
but
the more i've now that i'm doing replay
breath of the wild that's part of why
i'm doing it i think brett wilde might
be my favorite
tell him again tell him why tell him why
so he could understand
okay okay what's your least favorite my
least favorite zelda
you're not gonna like it spirit tracks i
hate spirit tricks
i like some of the more hated zelda's
though like i actually genuinely enjoy
phantom hourglass and stuff but uh let's
see what's the isolde is the answer to
this question right
true true all right fifth fifth favorite
series
i'd put gears of war uh i know this is
talked about but i actually
you don't see it in my background i i
collect every version of every gears war
so i have every collector's edition
i have the reprint trilogy they did and
then each of the standard editions for
all the games
uh because i i even have all the gears
war books i read the
gears war comics um the lore of gears of
war is something that nobody talks about
like the shooting is great it feels
perfect to shotgun somebody into
freaking confetti
but i i've always kind of respected the
fact that there is this interesting
alternate history of an alternate world
like if humans
that live on a planet that has 26 hours
days and is stuck in a
20-year war i don't know i i think that
that's something that's
it's not respected and talked about
enough hold on one second stop i need
you to reach slow mo
no i don't need you guys i have a frog
in my thumb sorry
all right i guess i'll have to read it
since he doesn't want to read it oh
slobo
the great slow-mo backslap from the dpa
subscribe to the channels dps firecast
y'all
only when he agrees with me i i'll
promote them
this is a weekly reminder that mass
effect 2
is the best mass effect best effect 1
age like dust in a pyramid mass effect
3's ending
with three colors of trash and andromeda
doesn't even
deserve to be called mass effect so with
that being said hold
on what's your top five well it's not
the magic that's those i'll tell you
that right
uh games or franchises or what what
you can do you can do games or
franchises you don't say
mass effect oh my all this capital you
don't say madison no no no no
he's he's different the hulk's different
i'll let him explain himself though
no i mean uh you know my top five games
or some combination they change in order
depending on my feeling and what year
we're talking about
in uh final fantasy vi
thank you thank you wait wait say the
second one that's a big win too
chrono trigger wow okay yeah he's trying
to divert that he said
yeah i'll try to ignore that you said
that yeah
which one was phil six oh yeah
apparently apparently
seven is better than six i love seven i
love it
um they remade the broken one first
that's why oh my god
let this is good stuff i'll just start
throwing games out there like grenades
yeah that's literally what's happening
yeah well you know it's a danger time to
say this but
witcher 3 is on my top five 100 it
yes it is um fallen out of favor of that
company a little bit in the last
couple of months um star control 2 has
been my top game of all time for forever
yes um and i don't know how many people
know it uh
but that star control 2 star control 3
less so
star flight there was an era of 80s and
90s pc games that were really invested
in um that kind of strange new worlds go
and find your own story
really open world sandboxy role-playing
in an era when it wasn't
possible um and as certainly a young man
that was
something that was really exciting to me
star control 2 stuck in there just
pitch perfect storytelling that's
actually been borrowed
across a lot of games that i think
absolutely your viewers would be more
familiar with
as we press on to 2021 and whatever your
car control dude came out
um but it's some combination of those um
you know more recently uh i think if
insomniac gets a couple more cracks that
spider-man franchise is probably going
to go up there
i really enjoy those i've gone back to
the original spider-man now
three times um so that's a lot of fun
right not the dlc right
uh the when you say dlc you mean miles
shots fired getting ready for the smoke
he's ready for the smoke today
miles was on my top ten in the last year
but it wasn't marked yeah it was it was
a fantastic i'm not saying it's not a
fantastic game i'm just saying this hot
dlc is good it's an ad
fresh you would hope [ __ ] it's a great
appetizer
i love it i love spider-man 2018 i've
gone back to that a couple times i'm not
too enthused about new peter parker but
uh yeah and i think some zelda mine
would probably be ocarina
okay uh okay that goes up there and then
what do you do with
the metal gears of the world i don't
know but you could tell from my list
that i like storytelling and narrative
in games and driving what you're doing
as part of the game and that doesn't
happen um
as much as i would like in the video no
you're absolutely right and uh second
part question that both of you missed
dreamcast guy i'm sure i'm gonna pass
over this because no i gotta hear i
gotta hear you i gotta hear it
i should already know what his favorite
cosmo of all time
yeah you you we can skip this but i just
need him too but
i don't need it oh yeah abs absolutely
the dreamcast actually i'll tell you
guys i have a secret video coming up
here in the next
10 uh that i've been working on for
about six months
i'm gonna put up on my channel i have
built the world's best
dream cast i have it being sent back
from an engineer now
i remade every single part of it custom
case uh
custom controller it has hd output i put
in a solid state drive so it'll never be
load times and it has every single
dreamcast game ever made
on it uh i've got a uh broadband adapter
so i can play the games online again
this dreamcast cost me about eight
hundred dollars and that's why i want to
make a big video called
i built the world's best dreamcast so
that's cool
look look forward to my dm sir everyone
you up very soon have you have you
played any of the uh
like the other the games that have come
out recently for dreamcast like yeah
i have yeah yeah uh rush rush rally
racing and i've pierced the lara pierce
solar and the great architects yeah
i get all the later ones they're so good
in fact
um i'm lucky enough that sometimes
people will send me the prototype so i
have some of those
they'll send me the game before they're
done so i've played stuff like
uh rizzo's island and stuff i get a
chance to play the new dreamcast games
they're
wow and they're still so good it's crazy
what what simple don't realize is that
the dreamcast ran a what was called
window ce so
basically it was the easiest thing to
make a game for except for the original
xbox the original xbox was even easier
than that but
a lot of like homebrew people who want
to experiment they still make dreamcast
games to this day that's awesome i had
no idea dude i cannot wait let us know
in that video because we gotta promote
it
that's awesome man lord hogue this is a
good one for you um
favorite console of all time i'm very
curious so you know i'm a lawyer so i'm
going to cheat
um but before i do i think my answer
ultimately would be the super nintendo i
think oh wow a lot of really big winning
games there but i want to go a different
direction
um for kind of dark horse stuff one of
the things that i really really
love that's gone now basically was an
era of
full motion video games that had
terrible acting and green screens and
i'm talking about sewer shark
night trap trap and dj and double switch
things that were on basically when the
cd was being
pushed as the prominent video game store
so there's a combined
console there that was in my house
between the cdi the 3do the turbografx
cd the sega cd
and those games that had you fighting
and b
movies against ants that attack from the
desert
and going through and trying to make
your fortune killing things in the sewer
and everything in between that was uh a
special time that sticks out as a moment
in history
yes because we see a little of it coming
back with kickstarters and things
and and and doing remakes and high
definition versions and night trap or
sure
consulting detective or all these things
that i worked on
uh back when i was you know a younger
person so that's i think
that's my favorite console that nobody
really talks about which of course is
like five
consoles but that's why my real answer
is super nintendo
on the record uh but otherwise i missed
promotion video i really like that and i
like the cheese salute to you what an
error it was because it almost felt like
they were experimenting they didn't know
what necessarily to do with the tech
initially just i was outside of better
audio right
and then the full motion wave just
started it like you said
just all these b level movies like how
they
that was the selling point that you used
for your parents
yes you know we use yeah
we we use uh sherlock holmes yeah
to get her yeah that's how i'm
consulting detectives yes my mom sat
there and watched me play a video game
for the first time she was like
when they were reimagining things like
uh you know isaac asimov's stories and
i remember really weird ones daedalus
encounter and they did rendezvous with
rama as a kind of missed alike with full
motion video transition
and there was all this fun stuff uh that
that breadth
of the game industry i kind of miss a
little bit because it just i guess was
a little bit cheaper a little fewer
resources to get something out the door
you needed a few less people to buy it
yes than you do nowadays uh but that
i i miss that i remember uh privateer
two um which was uh you know a spin-off
of the wing commander series
i love wing commando
and you had to make your way in the
universe and then there'd be like
movies yeah every starbase that you'd
land at
and i remember just being captivated by
that when i was a when i was younger
because that was just
it was just awesome that was everything
i wanted and of course you had from that
privateer and wing commander
you had the director show runner of
those games
then have a 250 million dollar grift for
the entirety of the early 20th dang
true though shout out to those those
players man 3d
productive that game will come out one
day maybe but you're going to have to
give him less money because right now
it's more lucrative to not come out
yes about this so i wanted to show you
so i have uh every version of the
sega cd because i think there you go i
have the the top loader the sides one
and the under underloader and then uh
sega randomly reached out to me when i
was doing my review of the
when i did the genesis mini when they
came out the genesis mini plug-and-play
nice so they gave me this weird it is a
micro replica that was never sold in
stores of a micro
sega uh 32x there's a little sonic
knuckles
but on the bottom there's even a tiny
little sega cd that's
awesome oh it makes me really laugh is
that you can actually you have to do it
appropriately it actually has the thing
where you pop off the bottom
you plug it into the fake expansion port
it's like this is such
and sega just was like there you go
dreamcast guy do whatever the hell you
want yo
that's awesome i remember having that
night i remember thinking that form
factor is wild when you got them all
stacked
up it feels
the sonic and knuckles and then you put
the game on top and then the game shark
the first the first youtube videos i
ever saw this is certainly true is i saw
a guy who had a uh
a sega nomad and he was sitting in this
like lamborghini
and he was sega nomad plugged into the
audio of the freaking uh lamborghini
he had like five
[Music]
it today great history great top fives
great consoles
loving this talk you know we love this
stuff we can talk all day poll results
last week pose on to it the people
spoken to the question
what it which what if gaming scenario
would have been the most
impactful on the gaming industry in an
alternate reality
the winner of the four-way iop poll with
67
of the vote was microsoft purchasing
nintendo
during the og xbox error
coming in at second place at 22 percent
of the vote was sony and nintendo
combining forces to actually create the
playstation group
coming in at third place and six percent
of the vote was the secret super secret
sega and sony console cd console talks
and at last place with four percent of
the vote was i don't care activision or
ea needs to buy wb games
group shout out to all those who voted
they voted for that one
we got four percent and we did get some
votes for
people wanted activision to do this so
anyway it is what it is
laura king you're the victor here um any
happiness
in a nintendo and microsoft future where
nintendo doesn't i mean microsoft does
the hardware
uh aaron uh please look at the poll
run it up the the flagpole make sure
that you know phil dominus maximus
really is spencer here's this and
hopefully nintendo hits their head on a
brick with this next console that we can
just swoop in and purchase them like
we're going to do project cd red
let's go that's the kind of purchase
that does get the regulators to look
twice
that that is that is a monopoly
just so we're clear that's the one where
they say you know what you do have to
send us your financial documents
so before we start we have andy crawley
with the five dollar super chat hey
lords get the extinguisher ready for
lord david
please don't rub your eyes after yes
please don't do that
um i have an ambulance there um gaming
forte with the five dollars which at
hogue you disappoint me i thought you
were an internet lawyer i can trust mass
effect 2 is goat
your eviction notice from michigan oh
he's taking mexican status from him
all right so let me tell you something
about lord cognito
so i've interacted with him now for a
couple years he's been great i've loved
coming on this show
ever since he found out that mass effect
2 was my least favorite mass effect yes
that we can talk about that if you want
i he has made it his mission to make
sure
every corner of the internet knows that
about me someday
if the hoglaw youtube channel in virtual
legality just takes off
there's going to be one person in the
comments you're saying did you know this
guy hates mass effect 2
and it's going to be lord cognito that's
the right hope you're on the right side
of history
don't worry about that i want that to be
his claim
you're gonna get cancelled for this this
this clip is gonna come up in
six years you're gonna hit a million
subscribers and people are gonna go i
have uh
some allegations about mass effect to
talk about
look how emotional he gave a fellow
michigan he's look how emotional he is
as i've always said here if you love
something love
something i'm not here to take away
somebody liking something that is
great if you're a game that you love
happens to end fighting a giant robotics
oh
what yeah
that's up to you listen youtube we're
going to do that when the trilogy comes
out we're going to do that debate show
solve hulk you know you're all you guys
saw on the best effect one side
we'll bring it back i'm looking forward
to playing it again oh yeah absolutely
we know why he's being held up because
great the three is actually the best one
okay
great great great action game by the way
to fix mass effect one is that what you
said yes yes all right
we gotta move this this is
you're up a lot going on man what's
going on but that's
what's happening yeah it's it's been an
eventful week so um
on monday we got an announcement from
disney that they were sort of
uh putting all of the lucas uh
properties under
a single umbrella like they used to back
in the day everybody remember lucasarts
um now we have lucasfilm games
which will sort of cover all of the star
wars properties
obviously indiana jones will talk about
in a second and everything else that was
under lucasarts before so all the sam
and max games
all of the uh you know there the
tentacle all of that
crazy stuff um no not their tentacle
that's something else
hey um is it okay
okay um you're good so
it's kind of bonkers that this is
happening
because it it didn't make it kind of
didn't make a lot of sense they do they
would just do this because
you know whatever they they own these
properties they necessarily have to put
them under the same umbrella
right so when this happened monday i
said okay i think we're going to start
seeing an influx of announcements coming
in
but what i did not expect was the
announcement that came in tuesday
which was bethesda coming out and
announcing that
machine games is going to be making an
indiana jones game
under the lucas uh lucasfilm games
banner
um and that i tell you it blew me away
because i said yeah
i mean it it's it's a combination that i
didn't know i wanted
uh but when you think about the nazi
stuff
that they're very good at doing
especially
their specialists
at hate groups um
i see no better combination and it's
just to me
uh i'm glad that now they are they
basically
everything that's under lucasarts
lucasfilms now is kind of free to go
where they decide they want to put it um
and that is fantastic to me and i think
this in particular was interesting to me
because of the microsoft involvement
um when they sat down to talk with the
uh
zenimax about you know acquiring them
obviously you know
i guess and hope elaborate on this this
is something you have to
you have to put all your cards on the
table right you have to if you're gonna
get in bed with one another
everybody has to be honest about what's
going on in the background what things
they have in the works
so uh it seems obvious to me that this
is a deal that was made
way back and microsoft was well aware
that this was coming down the pipeline
and if you think about if you think
about
where microsoft is somewhat lacking it
it kind of makes sense that they they
were even more interested to me this is
my opinion that they were more
interested in this stuff that they had
in the pipeline
even more so than you know the next game
from the
the dishonored team or the next
wolfenstein right those are great those
are fantastic to have in your stable
but this is the sort of stuff i think
that one that once they saw it they said
this is something that can get us on the
mainstream
without necessarily and it's going to be
encompassed within game pass right
right uh so one thing i think about is i
don't know that this is going to be
exclusive to xbox i actually don't think
it is because
i don't think that lucasfilms would want
that to happen um
i would say they want the games
everywhere that said the xbox
involvement probably means that it's day
and date game pass
i think that is money that microsoft
will put out there to make sure that
happens so
this is very interesting to me um
obviously we have more announcements
that addicts will talk about with the
star wars stuff
but uh what do you guys think in regards
to microsoft's involvement in this
and what it means for game pass what it
means for the for the indiana jones
franchise coming back to sort of uh
to a generation that hasn't really seen
indiana jones yeah that's a good point
let's start with dreamcast got first
then we'll get hold on the legal side
okay so confession i've never watched an
indiana jones movie
all right i don't know i know
they're quite
sorry i mean i will swear in front of
the lawyer
i kind of know what i mean i know i know
the major beats because of the memes i
know that the
the there's that chest and they open it
up and all the nazi faces melt and it
looks awesome and stuff but
i kind of want to keep it that way i
kind of want to stay in the dark
and play the games with a blank slate
whenever they come out in three or four
years or whatever
because to me i'll be able to go in with
no bias i've never watched
this or whatever yeah and i know there's
like the young indiana jones tv show and
stuff
i kind of want to go in and see what it
turns into
i kind of curious i had heard a rumor
a couple of years ago that microsoft had
said
we needed uncharted that was an actual
phrase that was said inside of microsoft
in a meeting right was
we need an uncharted and i think what
they always meant by that is that
we need to have an action-adventure set
piece that's just
a 10-hour adventure interactive movie
and i think
that that's what this is for them i
think they're finally going to have
their own
let me ask you a question right um when
they said that because i remember when
they said that and that's around the
time they had got that exclusive deal
for i think the system right
for the tomb raider yeah right because
they followed it right right after that
and people were in uproar thinking that
they purchased tomb raider when it came
out it was like a you know six to
whatever month
it was a year you're exclusive yeah yeah
exclusive
um do you do you think this was
always in their plans because they
looked at the level of success from the
tomb raider and looked at the level of
success from
the uncharted because i love uncharted
on playstation
and once like sovereign said they saw
bethesda
working with that game in the background
and machine games actually has all the
research to doing uh
alternate reality nazi game uh
with indiana jones and a story driven
thing
do you think that was the catalyst for
microsoft to
actually you know uh try to you know
obtain
zenimax because i mean just to see those
games in the background and to have that
original vision
of having a game of that story narrative
you know type of hoe
i i think it was it was half on purpose
and half a happy accident
i think that they were probably this
bethesda deal was probably years in the
making
and uh what you always hear is that
these companies are always working on
like 20 different tiny prototypes that
aren't ever going to get
i mean we've heard about cancelled final
fantasies and there was the resident
evil that's supposed to be on game boy
color there's constantly tiny
experiments and there was probably some
sort of like
you know little style of uncharted
prototype
and then when microsoft was acquiring
them and they saw and they got
permission to look at all their secret
stuff
that's when they're probably like okay
we can make we can put a whip in his
hand we can make this on uh
uh indiana jones i think it was a happy
accident i'm curious what it ends up
being i mean i hope it's not first
person i love machine games i think they
make amazing nazi murdering first person
shooters
indiana jones first person seems like it
would suck
it seems like a waste yeah a third
person game
i was going to ask have they made
anything outside of first person that's
a good question
not really i have no idea i always worry
about that transition you get a little
bit of
technical issues well you're seeing one
writ large right now when third party
third person cdpr moves over to first
person he brings some hassle
um you know talking about jedi fall in
order as i know lord cognito did earlier
i i think it has a lot of good ideas but
clearly has some
ah careful hit boxes and things that uh
become a company that had made first
person shooters
but i i would say one thing to to
to like combat that one thought right uh
we saw the the team that makes
resistance
and they switched over and made horizon
and
i i mean uh killzone kills that yeah
um suck a punch what you call it too
yeah and i and i thought
they handled it so phenomenally
yeah you know so i mean i i think that
the first person
shooter people already know the dynamic
world and they've probably been
experimenting with the third person
and they just like cut it out and just
went first person only yeah
i think they actually have a grip on
just saying
from horizon's uh perspective because it
came out so polished and so good
he did it he didn't expect it from a
first person uh you know shooter company
i
i agree no i agree with you completely
my question would be is that the
exception that proves the rule
right there aren't a ton of examples of
that in my opinion
and you know just to just to talk on
this issue a little bit i mean we could
talk about contracts
yeah i want to get your thoughts on the
announcement and
you know obviously the scuttlebutt is
can this
potentially be an exclusive for
microsoft a lot of people it's it's kind
of split i would say actually more
people probably leading
not but i think it is okay but it's a
split but what you think what you think
so bethesda
separate third party publisher enters
into an agreement with disney slash
lucasfilm games
right a year ago 18 months ago whenever
it happens
they licensed the indiana jones
properties they were going to make this
game
they promised to deliver it on a certain
amount of platforms those platforms
would be listed
on the contract when it's entered into a
year a year and a half ago
um that is not to sony's benefit sony
can't go and enforce that that is
between
disney and bethesda right then bethesda
gets approached by microsoft
sometime 12 months ago generally
speaking
what they announced it in the fall uh it
was probably being thought about for
the better report of a year okay and
they get as you've said they get to see
all those documents they would have been
under nda
uh the various third parties would have
had to have worked together to make sure
that they could see everything they
wanted to see
and that agreement would have bound
bethesda to probably delivering
on xbox and playstation and maybe a
cloud version or a port
on on the switch it depends on what the
contract says right right then microsoft
swoops in says we're going to buy you
and maybe they renegotiate that contract
and say well we want this to be
exclusive and then they talk to disney
and lucasfilm
the question is how does disney and
lucasfilm feel about that and ordinarily
i'd say well they don't want exclusives
right this is their brand
it's probably aimed to now release
somewhat close to indiana jones five the
movie
that's probably how these companies
operate yeah they want it out as much as
possible and everywhere
but maybe not if you go and you look at
marvel which is obviously not lucasfilm
as anybody can tell when you look at the
mcu in the star wars movies
marvel has elected to have single
exclusive games most
prominently the spider-man franchise um
and so
there is a certain amount of comfort in
institutional disney
with the notion that that could still be
okay right but you see even from marvel
avengers goes out to crystal dynamics
it's launched broadly
that was probably supposed to launch
against endgame
would be my guess right didn't happen
obviously um
and so you have a kind of mismatch of
contracts
i would say that indiana jones project x
is very likely to still come out broadly
um
probably because it doesn't make sense
to try to pay off that contract or to
get out of it
also because effectively a successful
indiana jones one
sells indiana jones two which is where i
would say it would be exclusive um and
so i think you can see
that kind of thought process probably
happening not guaranteeing it because it
could go either direction
in terms of the question of whether this
drove them to buy them i have to say
pretty pretty unequivocally no okay um
a single project years out on a
franchise that really wasn't all that
successful in crystal skull that is not
star wars indiana jones is great i love
indiana jones
isn't star wars in and of itself from a
company with an unproven track record
and making what we all assume will have
to be a third-person over-the-shoulder
type adventure game yeah
yeah and uh and it's it's likely to be a
success
maybe they have the skills we think they
can do it but it's not a guarantee
when you are spending seven and a half
billion dollars
the chances of a moderately successful
aaa indiana jones game four years down
the line is not even moving the needle
on the evaluation of that particular
acquisition in my opinion they still
were trying to move into rpgs which they
thought
was something that they could kind of
capture a bonus with bethesda and
they go in they get the ndas and say oh
you've already negotiated stuff with
disney
right that might be good the indiana
jones game might be good also we like to
have
more little people talking to disney
disney's a fairly large media company as
we all know
and so that doesn't hurt this deal at
all it's a little sweetener
but it didn't drive it in my opinion
okay i got you i actually want to ask
you a question um
and this is in reference to what you
mentioned
with microsoft swooping in after though
that relationship seemed to be
possibly already established yeah it
seemed like it would have been already
set up
have you seen scenarios where
companies would amend that language and
you know based on getting what your
experience like
would it be something very exorbitant
where based on the property like hey you
guys were indiana you have to you know
microsoft's gonna have to you know cough
up or whatever or
like have you seen that scenario where
they've it's been edited to say hey
we do want this after the fact it
depends so much on the personalities
and the leverage and what they're trying
to accomplish so
you look at it from disney's perspective
they enter into that contract it's
effectively yeah they want to make
revenue they're going to make royalties
off the sale but they wanted to
advertise indiana jones
right lucasfilm has had some floundering
in terms of lowering of
profitability over a couple of years
they're doing this to try to get into
games which are very popular and
coronavirus only showed them to be even
more so
yeah and so it's marketing and they
wanted to get out there
microsoft comes in how does disney feel
about microsoft probably they're two big
giants they're all
going to be business savvy and they want
to get together and it's all going to be
great and if microsoft really wants it
exclusive they would entertain that
conversation
but i've certainly seen instances in my
career where
they've got an acquirer of somebody that
you were okay with like a bethesda and
you just hate them
if disney just hated microsoft and i
don't have any reason to believe this
case in fact i think it is likely not
right but if they just hated them they
say nah we ain't changing our contract
if you want to buy them that's up to you
it's going everywhere and you can fund
it or whatever but that's the contract
they entered into and if you don't
deliver on that contract well we have
our own breach claims
we can bring against you thank you for
calling right otherwise
yeah chances are they're gonna get to
the they're gonna get to a table and if
microsoft really wants it to be
exclusive they say well
what do you want for it uh is there
something we can do in a different
capacity can we give you just a bunch of
surface pros can we just
i gotta be surface pros you know
that's well that's what they did with
gamestop right here's have some surfaces
it's all good and so that could happen
but
it's it's really up to the parties
involved and basically
the one thing i would have everybody
take away is any agreement can be
amended by the parties that are to that
agreement
it just depends on how everybody's
feeling and once it's signed up and you
have to go ask for something from
somebody else
uh it depends on how they feel about
that so so
so in the scenario where it they decide
that they they want it everywhere and
they don't want to give up that
exclusivity yeah
does microsoft still have the ability
well do you think
microsoft would be willing to pay
whatever amount of money necessary to at
least have it day one in game pass
well i mean i think so that's the other
component right so bethesda never would
have had a service to go with this
and it really depends on what that
agreement looks like this is a big one
this is disney big media company with a
big license going out to another big
company
so it's going to be a pretty well
drafted long license agreement
and it's going to have restrictions on
it you will
uh only sell it in premium storefronts
for the first six months before even
thinking about playstation plus or game
pass or whatever
that might not be in there but it might
be um because
in terms of us collecting our royalties
where we make money on this if we are
disney
we have very specific accountants and
bean counters looking at things in very
specific ways and we don't want you to
go
in a really weird direction that we
don't all agree on chances are
it's got a broad prescription on how
this thing will be sold when it is
finished
and knowing disney disney gets a consent
right
they get to sign off on whatever you
want to do with it and microsoft can
make things worth their while
the question is whether they want to and
again i i look at it and saying indiana
jones is exciting i love it i'm a kid in
the 80s
right i don't actually think it's
driving that much for the current market
this
is the sweetener the next story we're
going to talk about is the apocalypse
okay yeah okay i think that'll solve
really get the super chances that we get
out of
hold on a second we have a lot of
roughness with the five pounds of attack
yo please add me on xbox oh
you know king david otw
i beg to differ with those that say they
can't see the indiana jones game being
an xbox exclusive
bethesda announced this game on phil's
birthday
thank you so much i'm going in on this
one
okay then we have the the executioner
with the 20
super chat my prediction is that the
indiana journey i know it
is that indiana jones will be exclusive
disney marvel granted sony license to
create a spider-man
playstation exclusive so there's no
reason disney lucasfilm
would not grant a similar deal to
microsoft
interest um you'd have to buy it yeah i
mean so
when you think about a contract you're
getting certain things you get the
licensed indiana jones that costs a
certain amount of royalty
you get a territory to sell it and that
costs a certain amount of royalty or
upfront
payment you get it exclusive rather than
non-exclusive that costs a certain
amount of money
that was the negotiation that happened
at the front end between bethesda and
lucasfilm desert doesn't care because
they're selling it into every console so
i can't imagine
they would have asked for any specific
console exclusivity so microsoft swoops
in
and has to say lucasfilm we wanted
exclusive it's a new agreement or more
specifically it's an amendment to the
existing agreement
right and that microsoft can't even
negotiate that right now because i know
we treat it as a feta complete
as to this this minute that's not how
these things work
so they have not closed that deal they
have signed the agreement and commits
them to paying the 7.5 billion
the assets have not moved microsoft
really doesn't even have the capacity to
sign that on bethesda's behalf right
this second
got you so we all caught up yeah record
addict your thoughts bethesda machine
games executive produced
by todd howard i think can you guys hear
me yes sir yes
sir background by the way i str
i strongly believe that this is going to
be an exclusive
and the reason part of me does feel like
he could
i you know i want to state that i
do feel i could go 50 50. but there's a
couple things
that's happening that don't make sense
like for instance like
you know i the lucas um the lucas gaming
or
what is it called
this has been around but they're they're
using it for different purposes now
that they want to use it as like okay ea
royally
messed up our our star wars game vision
in the gaming industry so we're going to
have these people babysit everyone
and i think that's you know they you
know they probably hired a bunch of
people to help you know monitor all the
ips that they have
and i don't think this company to it to
the degree it's around now has been
around long
right because now you're starting to see
them talk all the time
you didn't the only time that that luca
because i looked the only time that that
twitter even tweeted was like a star
wars battlefront set
was on or something like they were never
active but now they're regularly active
and i think that i don't think this deal
was like a year
ago like people think i don't i don't
think it was relatively
soon but i don't think it was a long
time ago
and the reason i think that is because
the 10-year deal with star wars is about
to end
and i think this is when they started
looking at all the perspective in the
gaming they can do
right and that's when they started
reaching out to people they said 100
lord addict that they talked to ubisoft
on the next story we're going to talk
about
a year ago to start that relationship
let me let me ask you this to to to kind
of let's say defend without it
saying but to to cast some doubt which
is
you know i shout out to jessica window
central he actually put a tweet out like
it's kind of interesting that sony did
not
retweet the news and my cam again i want
to bring it back to you hulk like
is there any reason why they why they
wouldn't
they were microsoft could have bought
exclusivity i mean so i
i said microsoft can't sign on behalf of
bethesda right but because they still
have to get approved by regulators they
have to still get all their ducks or
they have to pay their lawyers a fortune
to move paper around and accomplish
nothing
and once they sound jealous you say you
sound a little envious dude
i agree with you guys about global hours
and not envious of the transaction at
all
so it's it cuts both ways it's a weird
job
but you know that still has to get done
microsoft could tell bethesda this is
going to happen
make sure that you this gets made into
an exclusive um
i think i can guarantee give or take we
don't make guarantees in the law for
contracts we can't say sure but 99.9
of the time that bethesda contract with
lucasfilm when it was originally put
together
was not for an exclusive platform right
sony not retweeting it might be because
they don't know
they might not have any idea that this
was even happening because
lucasfilm would have talked to bethesda
not sony um and microsoft found out
through an acquisition talk
not anywhere else good point no sony
mind oh this is news to us we have to go
make our calls and figure out whether
it's even coming to us and bethesda
might be like we have no idea because
it's
fun i've just seen a lot of scenarios
where games are announced
yeah and then the other person says this
is still on our platform you guys
i just i yeah i've seen that happen
multiple times and not to mention when
they bought
when they did the wasteland three and
the other awards playstation was still
talking about that
they they didn't just act like it
doesn't exist anymore
i i think they they're gonna pay for
exclusivity i
i say this just out of pure speculation
and pure gas but i think it's that
that uh microsoft just has so many
hundreds of billions of dollars i think
they realize that like sometimes you
have to pay for the other people to lose
in order for you to find that win and i
think it's going to be them just
saying like all right we own the studio
we're just going to pay disney enough
that disney is okay with
us using their toys only at our house
let me push back this is a fun one just
but that was advocate
what about to hoge's point that says
you know well indiana jones ain't really
popping like that like this generation
don't know about so why shouldn't you
try out a hundred year old harrison ford
i love indiana jones yeah but it should
it should have like harrison ford
he looks so bored in anything i know
yeah like he just freaking doesn't care
my guess i think that this game 100 i
think this game is going to be young
indiana jones and they're going to go
the direction of tomb raider and it's
going to be
the rise of indiana jones so indiana
jones and the first adventure is what
it's gonna be
and i bet the movie's gonna come out
with old geriatrics
and then at the same time i bet they're
gonna announce as soon as he dies on set
of an accident
all my future defense lawyers but in all
honesty yeah they
one line that they said in their
announcement was it was in the prime of
his career
so i i see it as kind of another
adventure in world war ii probably give
or take
but it certainly could i thought be i a
it was going to be an original two like
it's original state of atlantis style
which is one of the best lucas arts
adventure games ever
no no it is look so i'm going to switch
out the king's been patiently waiting
we've got mods gaming with the 10 super
chat exclusive or not it will be xbox
game pass
day one faction hello shane what's up
brother lord's gaming.
in the building my bro bots gaming
salute
like when it comes to let me finish my
yeah real quick yeah
when it comes to that i just personally
feel like the way twitter was wrong and
obviously twitter's not 100 anything
but there are certain scenarios where
you could see
the way things are going on twitter that
you could kind of you know get get a
taste of what's going on like it's like
i said like people wanted to go oh you
know
uh they were talking about the hellblade
stuff and they're like whoa you know
just because they didn't point out and
say
you know write out that certain games
are exclusive or not that that means
that it's not exclusive i'm like but if
you look at hellblade they never said
that about oblate either
and then when it was announced it wasn't
exclusive so
yeah so
no nothing one thing that i'm thinking
about now uh that sort of uh
clarifies the stuff a little bit for me
let's let's say even the like the game
pass argument right it's 15
15 million game pass subscribers right
now right 20.
all right let's
let's let's not use metrics from last
september let's keep going
between 15 and 20 generations between 15
and 20. so let's say by the time let's
say 20.
let's go 20. let's say let's say the
answer to exclusivity now is no like now
you're not getting that
and by the time the game's ready to come
out we're looking at 40
million game pass subscribers now maybe
the leverage is a little bit more on
microsoft i think yeah
your rationale is kind of scary and
right because you just said
it didn't move from september to now but
by the time the game comes out
by the time the game comes out we're
talking about two or three yeah they're
20 though okay
and i want okay so it's fine why are you
why are you a stickler for this 20.
right
he went there it's like hulk said you
know
uh you know indiana jones ain't really
popping like that but you can flip that
around it's like
you can pay exclusivity because it's not
popping like that
you're saying it like that i know he
said like you know
but it is true it is that thing where
microsoft could
come to the table and be like hey man
like listen let's be real here
i see what you're saying oh yeah oh
i get it man if it was something like
star wars to be like
okay i'm not paying what you guys want
right it's indiana jones this is the
last time you've been involved
okay okay indiana jones is lit
so he like that old rapper that was
successful back in the day
he ain't dropped that high he
we had a is good years and they never
talked about it again okay
i got you i see the mentality i see the
mentality uh so i'm super chat we gotta
get kicked out of this song
so we have we have let me go get
something to drink i gotta do this
we gotta stitch with the two dollars we
chat don't forget microsoft has
f you money to keep games in-house they
do
they they they absolutely do they i
don't know we
missed two of them we got we missed two
before that no i i got mods
no it was before mods before
you know jd always likes to come katie
gamer
given that it's possible that microsoft
needs to now negotiate the details of
indiana jones exclusivity
how much do we think microsoft will
spend to get it to one
game pass and then two xbox exclusivity
250 million question mark oh no
nowhere that's a whole studio that sony
just paid for
well the couple times there's been
leaked
exact numbers for exclusivity it's
surprisingly low
like the couple times i've seen
exclusivity contracts leaked it's like
3 million sometimes or 15 million it's
not like they're they're not paying the
whole cost of the game a lot of times
you just need to throw them enough that
they're willing to do it because a lot
of times it's like all right exclusivity
for so long like
so the metric yes so the metric for
exclusivity is some amount of math that
depends on the circumstance
that is okay if disney made this deal
because they were going to sell
a projection amount of copies on the
xbox and the playstation
you say okay we're just that projection
comes straight off the playstation we're
losing those sales
what was our royalty cut which isn't 100
what was our cut
yeah of those sales on playstation
that's a number facts
and then disney says okay that's the
number we want microsoft says no
this number and then sony says uh or
disney says okay
we come to an agreement between those
numbers or we're not willing to do it
without it and you know
you continue from there but that's
that's the baseline math there's a lot
of stuff that can go into it from there
modified royalties game pass streaming
services whatever
yeah so but that's your baseline we're
not going to make those sales anymore
what would we have made in dollars with
our projection
you owe us that so question hogue did
all right
is the conversation always only based on
the numbers
or do they have the conversation we have
like well indiana jones isn't where it
used to be
that's the projections right because
they're all guesses we don't have sales
numbers
so pretty much like oh they're like look
okay like we
we know that we might sell this much on
the playstation platform he's like
but for pretty much like getting
exclusive he's like give us that up
front
like so that way if we don't go like
because because they can always it can
always be less than they thought so they
they come out
it could always be more so and you can
cover for those things you can have a
contract that has a shifting royalty
that has more going to the license or
before you hit x amount of dollars
that is designed to share some of that
risk especially if it's something that's
a real big unknown
because the conversation we're having is
the conversation that they'd have let's
say that
uh disney just rolled in and they were
having this conversation they sat down
at a table does he says well
we've projected that our indiana jones
game is going to sell 20 million copies
on both systems in the first weekend
and microsoft says excuse me
you know what a lot of video game sales
is it's like no that's why we created a
third party outsourcing studio
and and then they say well we think that
maybe if we're really lucky it could it
could have sold
five million across both platforms and
then disney says no no no indiana jones
is and i quote
uh some of the folks on the iron lords
podcast uh lit
you know everybody comes into my
comments on my videos and says oh you
know corporate america has all this
research and all this money it's still
just human beings
it's still just human beings with a lot
of analytics that might be
fighting about different sets of
analytics and one side has a vested
interest in having that number high
and one side has a vested interest in
having that number low good point king
you've been patient what's going on
where you at all right first of all
uh lord a wet blanket holder
that's what a lawyer
what i'm going to do is cut that rope
and i'm going to fly with my man
dreamcast guy
right so um i think you wanted something
dreamcast guy
how are you doing i'm down with lord
dreamcast guy
100 because i say this right when he
said them bucks
no no no no but i'm the most
don't hate the player
but anyway i say this because he said
one point
phil dominus maximus are really
expensive has the bank
with satya so now that we're looking
over at odin
and we're like yo this is no wait we
back with this analogy okay let's go
let's go exactly we'll look over at him
and he'll say yo listen
you know they have that uncharted right
oh yeah we do like that game
and we couldn't really seal it down we
did good metrics when we had uh tomb
raider on for that first year
it really sold really well and then when
it came out on the xbox one x
it looked fantastic and people
gravitated towards it and when it hit
game pass this was the numbers that that
did
so what do you think we should do to
lock down this exclusivity
well being that we don't own them yet
but we will that's a foregone conclusion
hogue
now for you playstation fans out there
that are saying please don't let this be
true it's over
you guys got uh uncharted you guys have
tomb raider to share with us we are not
giving you indiana jones and i don't
care what anybody say
if it's not lit i don't care what you're
saying you're being a wet blanket now
yes
this blanket is for them so
we don't get uncharted over here we
purchase this company
for these reasons we appreciate it
dreamcast guy if you let us be messy
like you don't have that
he loves this stuff okay let's do it
so i'm just saying this right a lot of
you guys got your hopes and dreams
floating in the sky
i'm here to do a hole to you and pull
your legs down pull you back down to the
earth
microsoft is not going to allow that
game out of their stable
it's going to stay here if you want to
partake and this is the metrics they
bring to the table
okay okay so you want to put it on
playstation huh
this is what you're thinking huh this is
what i say to you
first we have xcloud so every phone you
know with the deals that we do have with
uh samsung
you know we'll have this app on it oh we
also have these tv deals
where the app will be on the television
so we have a ability to reach
billions at one time all right that's
not even talking about the 20 million
uh gamepad subscribers so let's look at
this and then those companies
that have i mean those those consoles
that we have sold
already previous consoles xbox series
consoles
and also the xbox uh one consoles
we have these consoles this platform is
viable to get you the metrics and
numbers
that you are looking for and that holds
says when they walk in the room
and if they say well you know well we
need x amount of dollars to make this
right well here you go
comes in and he throws the money on the
table and said is this enough for you
i got a tea date oh i got to
you know why it's very important
that's that one that you've been asking
for
this is the one you've been asking for
so
you are in not the minority you might be
in the majority
you might be the the the same group of
people that has been
dying for uncharted on xbox a story
driven
beautiful uh narrated game
for that console we need this win we
need this
this might be the thing inside game pass
that pushes it a little bit forward
at the monica subscriptions for them
well listen
i think the subscription service itself
will sell itself
once you put quality games inside of it
it definitely goes up it pushes the
needle forward no doubt
and i'm just i'm just i gotta say when
dreamcast was hitting those points
when he said that money
now one thing that really it makes sense
about what king is saying is this
and we've talked about and i gotta give
hogan yeah
how how do you how do you open up
the game pass to true big third-party
schools right
if you can do it in-house in in a
roundabout in-house way like this
with the purchase of xenomax and owning
this the studio that's going to be
making this game i think yeah because
again it opens that door for showing
other publishers hey
if you put your third-party game
day and day on game plans day and day
maybe
exclusively or not but if you're willing
to put it day and date in game pass
you will see these numbers x and and to
me
if you're going to try that at all right
the safest bet
is to do it with something that
eventually is going to be quote unquote
in-house for you
so i mean i could see it you know i i
i want to see because to me lucasfilm is
like all right we just
made this new umbrella we want to make
as much money as possible
that said like like like uh like stitch
said they
you know microsoft has fu money so it
can happen it happens
it's like good when it comes down to it
i do think that microsoft's biggest
intent right now is
they're they're trying to compete with
game pass they're not
trying to compete against game pass and
i do feel like
not them not taking that direction
because they've been seeing what's
happening like
they're it is not a coincidence that
everything people clown on
they slowly been taking off the chess
board for the past couple years like
the power narrative the no games
narrative and like you know let's be
real here
islam you know the i cannot believe i'm
about to say this oh
hashtag just won
they know that that is the biggest type
of game genre
yeah that they don't have and you know
maybe that they can maybe they you know
composure can make one
but it's just like what what would be
better for them to invest into the game
that they're already investing into a
compulsion that that can be a hit and
miss
or a name like indiana jones true i mean
because it's still not a new ip like cog
one it's still not a brand new ip
but that's it i said the power of a
third-party ip a licensed ip
couldn't con can could really be
powerful
after that i think let me just say
something real quick
let's we have to admit that when it
comes to like netflix
microsoft saw what was their downfall at
the beginning
it's that they had to rely on
third-party stuff like but now they see
you know netflix doing a lot better than
they used to because they started
implying their own content
that they don't have to lose because
they would lose the licensing or lose
the contract
and that that's where they've already
tried to like
try to cut cut it off it's like we're
not gonna go in with third party and
then not first party we're to go in with
both
right and i think that's that's why
they're investing more
into their first party than they would
invest into getting exciting exclusive
third-party stuff on gamepad
king the whole game i think the game um
is going to be young indiana jones like
you know the rise of you know indiana
jones type
thing like that i think the mcguffin
will be like he's in a um
like a pyramid or whatever and he
touches something that does an alternate
world where the nazis actually win well
i was
oh wow that'd be awesome you understand
yeah because they did those stories
so well like they really did actually
they built a great world and that's
that's another thing story
and character they're so good they make
dj
which uh they get a viable character
can we just automatic are we just gonna
automatically assume that they're gonna
go with the nazi route like
that's we assume that they're just gonna
that's the time period
but it'll be nazis i i i don't like
i'm talking about like their past games
where the whole game was that like
it was literally about killing nazis no
but imagine if the first game is called
rise of indiana jones and the second
pyramid but he's stuck in that timeline
so it's called the revolution of indiana
jones and he overthrows the nazi regime
look i i would play bj blast woods
and that that's the ability for them to
take what we expect from an indiana
story and flip it on its head um
yeah the question is disney let them
because
yeah disney would sign on to it because
like hole said
you know it's not hot like that
they're willing to train anything you
know what's crazy like
how how games you use to promote it's
like from the creators of
of this and that it's like so they're
gonna they're gonna socialize like i
could just imagine just to be like how
are you gonna promote this we'd be like
we're gonna promote it like we've proven
everything kill him now he's like no
you're not
it is what it is that's gonna give
hogan's chance to rebut and also the
we really touch about the the executive
produced by todd
todd howard's on this yeah that's a big
deal a lot
a lot of people think i'm i'm gonna tell
you this i think i think
that's a positive one people think it's
a negative thing a lot of people feel
like that's a negative oh
i think it's honestly i think it's name
only and that's exactly what i was going
to say
i think tom howard's at the point
because the once they get this this fire
goes
goes through whatever no it's not even
about brown leather no
it's not about hating on it's just that
his actual involvement in it to me
isn't going to be that great it's not
going to be i never see his name out
there like
that's about collecting a chat oh my
goodness oh wow
no i mean listen after this vial goes
through i think senior management
at at bethesda and zenimax starts to
sort of lay back
i don't think it's like that because
like maybe other people but todd howard
like he he's
he might as well have been working with
microsoft this entire time anyway like
a lot of their games have been heavenly
microsoft influence
they their devs have worked closely with
them for the past 10 years like
he might as well have already been
working for michael let me get ahold of
this because there's a lot of
god howard slaying that i need to know
that
i'm a white blanket right so i can
perform that
perform that service sir thank you a
couple things
one that struck me immediately as a
marketing agreement the todd howard
mandated as part of the bethesda
contract with the indiana jones that
when it was announced you get his name
on it
i don't think he'll be functioning in
any great capacity and i wouldn't want
him to i don't think he's done anything
great for video games
actively distracted from the valuation
of bethesda and xena max for a number of
years now
that all being said i don't think you
have to worry about it because he's not
running machine games he loves indiana
jones apparently and that's great i
agree
he's going to stick in his studio that
he's always
the reflections
this i think that this conversation
vastly overestimates the value of both
the indiana jones franchise
and machine games if you go look at the
sales of new colossus
good boy famously and the last one was a
dud let's keep it up
one of the reasons bethesda sold out at
quote unquote only 7.5 billion
is that they really haven't had that big
winner
even though i love arcane to death i
love the new prey one of my favorite
games the last generation sold nothing
nothing no nothing and that's why that's
why when
when i said that microsoft when they
when they put all the cards on the table
beyond all of those other franchises
like fantastic elder scrolls fallout all
that stuff
they saw this stuff and for me i think
we're going to see a shift
in bethesda and zenimax in the coming
years but we're going to see them doing
more licensed stuff
um i heard that second team at arcane is
doing some sort of fantasy
fantasy adventure games love arcade yeah
so i could see them
you know getting in bed with warner and
making a load of the rings game or
something like that so
i think this the other stuff that we're
gonna see down the pipeline that other
stuff that they showed on this table
is more licensed stuff that i think was
very attractive to microsoft
apart from the stuff again the quality
of the games
can't be denied but they haven't big big
they haven't been big sellers
so i think i think there's more to what
microsoft saw in terms of
third-party license stuff that we we're
going to see down the pipeline
finish over we got a more yeah and i got
no problem
with any of that i i think that's a very
big possibility i do have a problem
overall
and see this is going to offend certain
people on this particular podcast
assuming that microsoft and its big pile
of money and it's even bigger pile of
middle management and too many
chefs in the kitchen is going to
suddenly make these game developers
better i think the stuff that we have
seen from the studios that they have
bought have primarily been things that
were already mostly baked
before microsoft got it and microsoft is
now working on a decade and a decade and
a
half
of not really bringing things across the
finish line in the same way that sony
has regardless of how you feel about
their particular products right they
clearly have the magic touch in
one specific the over the shoulder right
over the shoulder third person
they continue and an xbox
doesn't they they remake halo it kind of
goes out with the whimper they continue
to try to make gears
work and maybe it kind of does even when
it's a great game it's not really
selling very much
game pass is a brilliant move and it
will work
eventually but is this the way they're
going to do it and are they going to
suddenly make bethesda's output better
i don't know and for everybody in your
chat that's mad at me for badminton
i think like every superstar in every
industry there's a time and a place for
that person and then that time and place
goes past them and and i think the time
in place
when they gave him that check for the
buyout when he gets that
that time in place let me
answer hope all right xbox dude just in
the chat
all right y'all y'all y'all hear this
right
and and i give a shout out to every xbox
exec that's watching
all right and there's nobody watching
because we have two superstars on the
panel so they're definitely watching
i i say this to say this they're
challenging you hold
on hog is challenging you to make great
games
hogue is telling you that your time has
passed you by and i'ma tell you right
now i believe that you and your prime
because phil dominance maximus are
really expensive understands
what is wrong and what needs to be done
and the change
started with flight simulator so i'm
going to tell you guys
exactly looks laughing yeah stay focused
and stay vigilant
don't let him pull you down stay flying
in the sky
you know but you're lucky let's keep
going i'll back lord king up on this
hey if if they wind up proving me wrong
nobody is happier than me
yes we wouldn't need your knees though
we would need your knees for that
that would be an odd camera needs for
the slanted to the xbox community you've
been doing it the truth though i want
more and better games out there
absolutely i have my doubts about them
but
that's what i want if that's right then
great not fair enough
let me jump in and we would get a drink
get you laughs i just wanted to make one
last minute joke i went to
uh we've gone to quakecon the last
couple of years and almost there i was
there they they let me go to the vip
room while they're getting ready to show
off fallout 76
i
and he's like five foot two he's super
tiny
yeah and uh he had like three bodyguards
for these huge dudes
and it made it look even smaller it
looked like he's wearing a little kid's
leather jacket
all right i guess gonna get a little bit
of this pizza here
he like goes up there and i kind of
talked about fallout 76 and i was like
oh no
now whenever i watch his conferences i'm
like oh that's why he's always sitting
down you know oh
you know to me i don't know what's gonna
happen this is truly one where i
don't know what is going to happen i
could legit see
both hog king g cast everybody's
scenarios
everyone for me scenario
i could clearly see the vision of lord
attic in all its glory
that was it the lord added anyway
anyway he took his camera so look at the
end of the day it's just one of those
things where
to me the victory is still in game pass
it's still in game pass at the end of
the day at the very least
regardless of what happens in the xbox
ecosystem this will most likely
be in game pass now the other thing is
that no one mentioned that i know i'm
gonna go elaborate i'm curious
if one year time exclusivity could be
also on the table
you know what i'm saying with something
like this i don't know you know again it
turned out like like hulk said with the
numbers the negotiations
that kind of stuff and i just want to
transition on i think it's interesting
to me
you know i'm saying that you know lucas
or luke stars games is
now in this mode where like yo we're
going to be giving other people stuff
which is going to transition us
into the next topic so let's move on
which is
we got that star wars butters addict you
want
anything to say about it before addict
starts let me just get some checks
that's a couple of
stats so we have geek head 188
pause two dollars three hours of chat
king woke up and decided to speak facts
then we have clutch man with the five
dollars which i if we had hog law for
every podcast the gaming community would
be cleaner than my credit before i
turned it
jesus then we have pixel the g with the
5
super chat microsoft over paper but
that's the even more reasonable to make
everything exclusive
t he great casper
tv
are you back sir off strike for not
getting recognition for every point made
he's in space i don't know
[Laughter]
see the the the space thing this is this
is me flying out of here because i'm
just not feeling
you know anyways seriously
good transition now that we're in space
what's going on man lucas state what's
going on man star wars what's happening
so apparently the uh you know the the 10
years of hell i call it with ea
they they've had 10 years of exclusivity
on star wars games and it's
i can't say it was entirely bad because
i don't think it was entirely bad but
you know we had that fiasco with
battlefront and it is
i i don't think battlefront was like a
horrible game or anything or even the
second one but i do think that
in terms of what i played when i was
younger with the original ones
it was a little it fell short and then
you know we
we got the the famous like seven games
canceled in the ten years i mean we
they had a at one time they had a dark
moth game that was canceled
they had that uh 1912 what was it called
the 1313
13 13. they had that canceled so you
know there's been a lot
before ea yeah there's been a lot of
mismanagement going on
with uh ea so like now
it seems like that's over it seems like
this this new
entity uh it's going around babysitting
people so
i think they're going to be a little bit
more open to taking a little bit more
risk in terms of
who they work with with the star wars
franchise because
obviously you know like hogue said that
they're literally probably putting every
contract we get the last say on the
majority of the things in terms of
especially lord because they're really
big on the star wars lore and they don't
want to mess that up
that's normal yeah so like what i want
to bring to you guys is like do you
think
do you think we'll start seeing better
quality star wars and more star wars and
games in general
uh and i don't know if they confirmed
this but has did ea confirm that they're
even going to continue making star wars
yeah they did yeah has a partnership
with uh lucasfilm games they'll be
continuing their relationship
pretty much and that yeah that's what
their state was their statement was that
they're
already wanting to do something like
another uh fallen order and they said
we will continue working on star wars
stuff so yes it's confirmed they're
doing it and everybody else is doing it
so
yeah lucasfilm can went out of their way
in the statement and the if you go look
at the ubisoft post
the last three paragraphs are about
uh don't don't just hate on ea you only
hate ania a little bit
and i i have a i have a particular
question for
uh for king anyone else can answer the
king in general
king gun to the head right now microsoft
has the opportunity to make one
star wars type of franchise what would
it be one star wars game
who would make awards
oh okay one star wars game
i would have obsidian make the
mandalorian
yeah could use the story yeah i would i
would i would have
obsidian make uh the mandalorian i felt
do you feel like lando laurie would be
an rpg i feel like be a third
person cover shooter see i i don't want
it to be that
i want it to be uh uh rpg because all
right if you watch the mandalorian he
built his armor from the beginning of
the
the series when it started he didn't
start off with uh you know the best car
and it grew so wouldn't it be like
you're building up your armor you're
getting your stuff ready as you have to
go to
planet to planet and you're getting
different guns and you're building your
ship up because remember his ship kept
getting tore up
and he kept meeting different people so
it's a vast worlds of npcs that you can
meet you can have a rpg element
to it and i honestly think
that would be a fantastic game it will
have uh you know long legs too as far as
the rpg element to it right i don't want
it to be
the typical you hear star wars and you
you have to fight with lightsabers or
you have to do cover shooters or
you know stuff like that i want it to be
a little bit different a little bit more
a little bit more robust i want to learn
about the world
and you know i think obsidian would do a
great mandalorian game
with obsidian are you suggesting that
you're unhappy with the lore put forth
in the mandalorian plot line in this
season no no
no no no no no actu actually oh man no i
don't
the mandalorian grew from season one to
season two
and it ended higher
than any uh series of like
like a tv show or whatever it's climax
that last episode spoilers
time no people saw that if you didn't
i'm just saying that it ended on such a
high
note yes and it gave so much legs i mean
i believe actually that last episode
sold two more seasons no definitely no
time on mandalorian because this could
be a regular podcast i'm sorry
but we got a lot of television i've got
one not the mandalorian i don't love the
mandalorian that's fine i was joking
about the fact that man of lawrence
collecting best car in fortnite right
now
yeah exactly moving on to well i know
dreamcast guys
i was gonna real quick because i know
you guys are destiny fans i actually
would love to see a game called like the
lost
years of the rebellion and it be about
those early times when the rebellion was
just
endlessly and uselessly bashing itself
against the empire
but have it done by bungie i would love
to have the idea of daily quests i love
the idea of gear
i love the idea of just co-op for
everything drop and drop out
and honestly they're the kings of fun
aiming and pulling the trigger and that
real good kickback and i think it'd be
good to have that what that's the
biggest problem i've had with
battlefront the new battlefront games is
that
shooting feels like crap if they make
that
fun to shoot you can you can put this
the star wars skin perfectly on it no
doubt
no doubt i agree so back on track i
could
try to get back with this whole star
wars thing so obviously the licensing
agreement you know what i'm saying with
ea
and that you know what uh lucasarts
games again and then uh looks like that
deal has been altered so it um looks
like they could no i wouldn't say so
not altered no i wouldn't say so so they
entered into it in may of 2013
uh and then in november 2013 we found
out it was a 10-year agreement
right um so it ends in may of 2023 right
you
need to alter it to announce development
of games that are going to come out
after may of 2020.
okay okay gotcha didn't know that that i
didn't know that so according to the
what is it
vice president or whatever they said uh
um you know obviously
i love hope i know he goes correct i
like that i like now you need
we need accurate information i'm all
about accurate information
so look you know at the end of the day
it's going to be ubisoft massive you
know they're going to be handling and
obviously massive from
division fame you know kind of thing so
looks like they're going to be doing it
so i just want to get whole getting i
know you're a huge
fan of i am and just your thoughts on
this whole process
we're basically well we can't say alter
but you know
using presumed exclusivity so this is
good yeah
no you can just it didn't have to alter
the contract but it absolutely changed
the outlook of people for start
you know the thumbnail on my video from
wednesday was star wars freed
yes yes it is it is one of those and i
don't hate ea
and i'm glad that ea's gonna keep making
their games but it was locked into this
kind of really multiplayer focus
right not what i want out of star wars
you know i i love
the adventure and the heroism and the
lore and all that stuff and battlefront
is
fine but it's battlefront
it's not it's not doing that jedi fallen
order was the closest to do that and i
would
and i think jedi fallen over two will be
a big leap up now that they've learned a
few things i'm looking forward to that
one
um but no i was very excited about it i
continue to be very excited about it
i think a lot of people that commented
on my videos said well i'm not a fan of
ubisoft and they have their ub game and
all this stuff and i think
the one thing i would say that's the
most important here
that ubisoft did not get an exclusive
contract these are not your 10-year
lords for the next
decade this is lucasfilm and disney
saying this didn't work giving it to one
company any company esu
didn't work star wars fans were used to
getting
four or five games a year or 18 month
period
three of which would be junk two of
which would be okay
and one of which would we could convince
ourselves was actually great when it was
probably just okay
power battles yeah but sure sure power
battles
great masters of terrace
i can't make the sale for that one but
yeah so
i look at it and say even if you don't
like ubisoft even if you don't like the
next
contract that they announce this is a
better world if you're a star wars fan
than it was the day before
because you've got a better chance of
something coming out that you'll like
doesn't make any promises as we know
from being star wars fans since disney
bought it in 2013.
lucasfilm can make mistakes they can
make miss steps they can fire directors
90
of the way through filming whatever it
is that they might do they could still
do it
but you're not locked into one business
plan you're not locked into one
management structure you're not locked
into how do we monetize this where the
micro transactions
you'll probably still get that from the
ubisofts of the world but it will be
different it will feel different
massive you know we don't know what
they're making based on their most
recent output of division
we can assume it's probably something
like
bounty hunters and smugglers and
shooting in something that resembles
division
did the ceo say narrative driven open
world star wars game
you did it did but narrative driven open
world star wars game so is the division
two narrative driven and open
no no i mean i mean oh you're asking me
from my corporate
standpoint can you say that i mean yes
you can
if you want to play semantics see i
don't think it's semantics it's got a
story
it's got mission structures it's open
world you're collecting loot
i think it could very much be division
star wars skin edition right i would
love that i think people think of it
like it's assassin's creed
i don't think it's that gotcha yeah
because when i hear massive
exactly what i when i hit when i see
first one i hear the developer of all
massive and then
obviously when you see open world i i
yeah i wouldn't i would lend to believe
what you're saying
right now you know i want the immortals
team to get it you know just i want to
fly around and do jedi stuff with the
immortals team because i love them right
now fine
but yeah i think it's great i think a
lot of people
we'll see soon whether or not lucasfilm
games
is intending to just kind of shop it to
all the aaa developers
or where they're gonna we're gonna get a
more games workshop
warhammer 40k approach to licensing is
open folks
and we're going to try to put certain
controls on it but otherwise
we're not going to say no um i think
you're going to be
much more likely to find the former
disney is notoriously cautious
about control of its intellectual
property yes um so
while i would prefer the warhammer
approach which essentially results in
you know three layers of junk and then
the occasional like just gem
coming out um i think we're likely to
get a very cautious approach but with
more companies comes more products comes
more possibilities comes more successful
more darts at the dartboard no doubt
phantom saw super chat
played a good warhammer game oh my god
there you go i'll go with it i'll go
with it
he's out of control i love it i love it
you haven't played a good warhammer game
dawn of war dawn of war
ii what's the most recent i just played
chaos band
yeah i like i like chaos spain yeah it
was free to play
i picked it up see this is why i tell
you that partaking inside game pass type
of thing
i would have never picked it up right i
would have never plucked down
the cash but the free to play stuff and
i saw it there for free to play i was
sitting there bored out of my mind
and i clicked on it and you know i was
just like wow this is really good and
then the next warhammer game i'm looking
forward to so when you say like three
layers of warhammer
because their method of licensing is to
invite everybody to say here's a rate
effectively
you can have warhammer we're not going
to control it that much so you get these
tiny companies
in croatia or wherever putting together
the best game they can and a lot of them
have really good ideas but a lot of them
are not what we would consider triple a
they are like half of a 1a okay
fan enough all right
you get the mental image hogue wakes up
because uh
i'm just gonna poop all over every video
today
i love these games that's the thing i
just
we have to be honest about what they are
fair enough
so i'm gonna get this uh this is michael
aka bedsides finance with the five
dollars if it's that this slander will
not be tolerated in the xbox community
honor for them i guess this is the one
guarding them oh god
i'm guarding them okay i'm guarding them
um yeah so uh i guess this is todd
howard slander
um then we have i'm gonna get killed
after this
he's still welcome back home yeah we
have
if he's if if he's if he's dead
[Laughter]
yeah we have king one supreme five
dollars if it's at how many rp too many
rpgs on xbox coalition maybe uh make a
mando or han solo game please
okay are there too many rpgs on xbox am
i forgetting like all of them
he's thinking about what's coming yeah
that's what it is
then we have slow-mo backslap with the
five dollar super chat julian garrity
former division director said it's going
to be a completely
completely different from uh what
massive entertainment has done before
slo-mo is the division expert so i would
definitely defer to him and massive
bioware said a lot though oh my god so
we caught up
yeah star wars ea kind of losing
exclusivity ubisoft massive
where are you at with this thing man uh
very positive i mean the thing is that i
i think that we're gonna get
more bad games i think we're gonna get
more great games i think it's that
this is very much i'm a huge believer in
the
rising tide lifts all boats and i think
that opening the flood gates a little
bit which seems like what disney's doing
is disney realizes okay
we have so many different facets of star
wars now
from the cartoon show clone wars to now
the mandalorians
to the big freaking movies i think they
realize that okay this is too much for
one conglomerate which is ea to handle
so i like that they're
kind of taking the torch and handing it
to a bunch of different people
um i'm nervous that we're gonna get some
bad games i
am a little bit afraid that that some of
this is just gonna turn into crappy cell
phone games and stuff
but i bet that in 2023 there are going
to be
some weird game of the year
conversations of multiple star wars
games once they're able to really drop
all these projects
i think that's going to be the weird
year of star wars
i i am most curious probably about that
division project the division team
um i got bars for that continue they
they know graphics and realism in such a
way uh i i think that part of what i
love i just watched mandalorian for the
first time i just binged it
last week yes it's super late to it and
what i enjoy the most is there is a
grittiness to it everybody's armor's got
scuffs
on stuff uh and i think that they are
the singular team i would
trust to perfectly translate the used
aesthetic
into a star wars game mm-hmm i'm excited
that's fair enough
lord addict star wars connoisseur what
you feeling
i think this is good i i am a huge you
know i i wouldn't say i'm like
into the star wars franchise like a lot
of people are like i'm like the kind of
person that i go in
and that'll be go away and i i enjoy
the lore but then i leave
yeah i don't stay too long for the whole
crowd i gotta get it get my pieces
like i'm the kind of person that if i
get into it too much
i don't leave yeah and i'm already with
that with like destiny
obsessive i ain't trying to get like
trapped into another trap hole and then
i'm there for the rest of my life
like you know i think that it's good
because i think we're going to get
different talent to work on different
types of star wars games
obviously there is going to be some cell
phone games i think that's that's
apparent
you know what's what games aren't doing
cell phone games this stuff
i just hope that they don't try to do
the cell phone model to a point on
consoles that's my only help with that
no doubt let me know
one thing i can say on the cell phone
question is that the original license
from 2013 was only for core games
star wars mobile games have been
licensable by anybody
for this whole year for a long time let
me get my man geno black game you know
he switched it i still homie geno black
gaming ct what's up
he said you guys all have great points
but you're way off we need an ewok game
make it so you can craft crickets and
sell them all over and
i'm with that guy gino what's up baby
it's good
all that good decisions some economic
simulators in here
no doubt anyway let me get uh
ass off man what you thinking man star
wars the whole bit
i'm excited about this man i think star
wars never had any business being under
one banner in terms of game development
you know uh
i'm per you know i we're child's
children of the 80s and 90s that we had
you know those super star wars side
scrollers we had
all kinds of games some of them weren't
great some of them were fantastic and
they wouldn't get that again but
at the end of the day man like it's star
wars like
star wars belongs to the streets
belongs to the streets
people lost to the streets yeah i tell
you man there's
nobody being like like hope say like no
business being under one banner
with one way of thinking okay with only
the ability to make certain types of
games
and then you because you limit yourself
so i
with this now i think with the creation
of the new banner and the new umbrella
for me it i i do think we will get we'll
get your phone games
but i think in terms of a quality bar i
think overall the quality bar is going
to be higher
than what we saw in the past in the past
i feel like the star wars license was
kind of all over the place we got some
great games and we got some so some not
so great games but i think now it this
allows them to sort of pick and choose
developers
that make sense for particular types of
games i can't even imagine the amount of
pitches they're receiving
right now right yep yep i just i really
think
it at the end of the day we we're gonna
get these small games i just talked
about it like an ewok game but the most
interesting thing about star wars
is the like the dreamcast guy said the
greediness the underground stuff that
you don't necessarily
seen see uh when you're watching the big
movies or something like that
uh it is the smaller show it is the the
details that you see in something like
clone wars in mandalorian right
it is the stuff that you see and like in
in obviously it says the canon
anymore but a lot of the written stuff
right so it's interesting that now
we have the possibility to explore those
sort of corners of the star wars
universe
that don't get seen right in the big
production facts
so i think it's great i think it's great
i think this is what needed to happen
and like i said
i'm glad that ea continues to work on
them because battlefront we're all
intensive part
now right battlefront is an exemplary
product right now i mean it wasn't when
it came out it has
plenty of issues but for people who like
that type of game
that game is great right and and with
fall in order i do think that you know
handing it to respawn and the
story based narrative thing is what a
lot of star wars heads really want
you know they want to get into the
nitty-gritty of what star wars is not ev
everything doesn't have to be jedi and
lightsabers effects
yeah i want to see the grindy parts of
star wars you like rogue squadron type
stuff
yeah okay star wars ruby where you at
um all right so i think you guys are
onto something as far as the division
take
uh of like a star wars game i thought
that battlefront could have really took
off further than what it was
had they had somebody like bungie
working on the gun mechanics
right because when you pick up the uh
you the gun play
is damn near 100 of
any first person shooter game if the gun
play
is really on point then you most likely
will stick around that's what made us
stay in destiny
you'd be like oh the story is kind of
whack i didn't like this but that gun
played though
like you know if you lost in a battle
you lost because of
you and not because of you know the gun
mechanics or whatever you didn't feel
that tactile feel to it
right um i think that massive done does
a great job
with the division yes i think the
division
lacks a couple of things that can change
it into something else
and i think those things are found in
star wars
right uh well-known uh villains right
right and then the guy with the hoodie
exactly
you know like the dude would double up
armor yeah he was in ranking
fans all the time the raid is never i
hate to interrupt because you're on fire
no yeah i'm saying but yeah that's what
breaks immersion with division but if
you have to fight them in that manner
right
distinct enemies doing distinct things
on distinct worlds facts you know
imagine what they can bring to the table
and i think this would be a sure-fire
hit for them
uh if they're able to do like you said
you get that armor you know you get
those uh
that looter shooter feel to it like yo
what did you get those boots
did you get the gun and not like like i
said
it's not has it doesn't have to be jedi
right you know maybe that's one of the
bosses inside a raid
that you're fighting a jedi or something
like that or fighting a sith lord
and you have to do a mechanic to get him
stunned
and you know two people go this way and
you know it's just different things that
they can do i know they had a good
template with the division and i think
they grounded it too much because
destiny law
took us so far out they wanted to be the
polar opposite of it
but now with this franchise you're able
to even go
into that same grittiness of the
division
but also that that world that fantasy
world of star wars
yeah right so i think they will have the
best of both worlds i think they can
bring it and their aesthetics are good
because we saw the division two
and we said damn it looks good yeah
you're on fire let me let me jump in
because i mean you want in the same type
of pop
pocket um look first point like what
hulk's saying what sorry saying
an addict is saying so adam can
understand that we agree with addict
here from the matrix
from the matrix even though you're in
nature i like the vocals i like the idea
of the properties going other places
when it's locked in and you got that bad
deal
you're stuck so i like that you know
disney and them they
they're moving on from that old
structure right that's the first thing
the second thing is i'm with king 100
as much as i slam the division being a
destiny fan i cannot take away what
dreamcast guy said
snowdrop engine is phenomenal looking
it is for now that engine the the
day-night cycles
the rain the weather now you put that in
that type of universe
could you imagine off with the snow and
and you had to do play survivor
fire and you can climb inside a bantam
yeah like see i'm a star wars dude like
you know in trust me i can go to that
place i can see cell phone games of baby
yoda i could see that stuff
i understand it right i know you guys
are fearful for that but think about the
upside of it
not so much of the downside those games
has to sell to you know whoever
my daughter needs to have to play candy
crush with you know baby yoda heads or
whatever
or ewoks making cookies and bacon cookie
factory
but i knew when disney got the franchise
and he spent x amount of billions for it
right
they were going to make sure that this
stuff was going to be marketable and
sold you heard dreamcast guy just said
he just watched the mandalorian he binge
watched it and he loved it
right once it reaches to everybody
on every pl everything this is what they
wanted to do and i'm so happy that we're
getting
back to it because remember when star
wars was on genesis was on super
nintendo
was on here and was on there and then it
got segmented to like one little thing
and i'm i'm happy that it's going other
places no i agree the last point i was
going to say like i said we
we talked about how we like all right i
got you um you know in this whole thing
and it's just like
look my only thing negative about this
is rp division bro
it's gonna be on this and and division
fans have been wondering division two
fan like yo what's going on what's the
latest updates without hearing
optimizations we're not hearing
anything you know major down the
pipeline now we know
because this is where resources are
going to be
so um yeah man like that that's pretty
much it that should report
supported it harder yeah division slower
i agree division three ain't
ain't happening he said all my place
take one round's the hoodie yeah no
doubt
look i got no slander for the engine and
i i think it's gonna be a good look but
we got to move i do want to get hold of
the whole gotta leave shortly but i want
to start him more first with the this
topic that we're gonna just bum rush
into if you have a maybe
10 more minute talk or something yeah i
could do 10 more all right cool let's
go something super fast i randomly ended
up
at a star wars actor's house recently
and at their house they had a full star
wars museum built
with all sorts of like original stuff
from the movies and this is
a painting of the original star wars
poster
super weird just like all their stuff
was like original props from the movies
and stuff
it was super super bizarre so let me
just tell you i don't know it's it's
interesting that like star wars i think
the people that are working on star wars
care just as much as the fans
part of why i feel like this disney deal
happened is that they realized okay more
people should experience this freaking
amazing universe
absolutely finally look we're going to
move on because we got hulk for a couple
minutes i got to get his thoughts on
this whole situation so i'm gonna set it
off look
we all know what's going on cyberpunk
2077
the whole
look you know obviously we saw the
apology it went out you know what i'm
saying
and um yeah they had some things to say
and reference to it as far as the um
co-founders personal explanation of the
what happened to the days leading up
to the launch so we saw that most of you
guys saw the video
and then the second thing which came out
rather you know shortly after that was
um
lord jason schreier who we've had on ilp
before
you know how bad it must be to be a
company
and wake up and be like man jason dumb
made an
article about us
we're gonna get into both aspects of
this so for fairness right so
the first thing he came out he said look
he had it said uh what went wrong with
cyberpunk
he said he had over interviews over 20
current and former cd projekt red
staff to paint the pictures unchecked
ambition technical roles unrealistic
deadlines and above all one belief we
made the witcher 3
it'll work out so some excerpt excerpts
from it
you know i'm saying that you know dev
said that they despite promises to
crunch that uh uh
not be mandatory they felt pressured to
work overtime on and off for years
he goes into um similar things to like
how the anthem does mention where they
talked about the bioware magic this
unwavering belief that
with enough hard work and crunch their
gangs would come together and uh cd
projekt red was similar he said when
asked about unrealistic deadlines
directors said they'd be fine they made
the witcher 3 after all
some tidbits that were also cut from his
article where um
veteran des were from other companies
were shocked at uh cd project red free
for all production
for example if someone needed a shader
they'd make it with no pipeline in place
to determine whether someone had already
made one
with the same function and then the uh
one of the last points they were saying
just in general you know about the
culture about unrealistic deadlines you
know
maybe possibly coming out 2022 the whole
bit so look let me give it to you hulk i
know hogue has some spicy things to say
in reference
to this argument but in your defense um
the actual studio head oh forget his
name adam
can't pronounce the last name but dallas
wadowski right
he um actually fired back that lord
jason and he had some
some things to say in reference to that
you know yeah i would i could if i could
see these
unfortunately i'm blocked by mr schreier
i disagreed with a few things that he
said and one of those honestly that was
that
honestly i think when it comes like
jason schraar i wouldn't even attempt it
man i'll be like
you got that fam that's you i'm out like
i literally replied to his what tweets
once is you're such an intelligent guy
it's baffling you get things wrong so
often and he said you seem like a
pedantic
loser or something like that and block
me black game of lord jason
it's legendary we know we've had them
all here before the list
is a vaunted and select crew
you have earned the honor but what i
wanted to say just reached it just to
hit the rebut from
yeah this guy is pretty much he just
said look because oh one of the big
things that came out of the article
was that the 2018 demo was completely
fake you know according to yeah we could
talk about that too because i think
that's a little bit strong
so you can finish your intro i will say
i mean i tweeted this out
yes um i i like a lot of jason
schreier's work i also think he gets
things wrong from time to time he tends
to editorialize when perhaps i wouldn't
right in this particular instance this
article
it feels much more hollow than even
usual from him and maybe that's because
cd project
has gotten out in front of a little bit
of it right especially with the
marcinavinsky
commentary earlier this week but
when when he says it's fake i you know
i've worked enough with game developers
and i don't pretend that my clients are
electronic arts or activision or anybody
like that but i've worked enough with
folks that are preparing for
conventions of smaller stature than e3
and occasionally some bigger ones
and you're always creating a slice a
demo an e3
thing right that is different right um
and and is that fake in some functional
definitional way
yes right is it intended to show what
you think is
really common probably right and so
you know yes it's fake and yes you see
developers complaining about the fact
that they spent whatever it was
six months working on that thing right
that is a common refrain across
everybody i bet you could find
naughty dog employees talking about that
last of us part two
demo that they did when they made
everybody walk in a church
and that's a very common thing where it
tends to pop up is when things have gone
wrong and then they say oh we should
have been working on something else
but to the to the credit of the company
and you can go and you can look at my
channel and see 14 videos where i think
they're doing stupid things
to the credit of the company they don't
make those pre-orders they don't become
the most hyped game
of 2018 19 and 20. they don't get to
where they were moving into december of
this last year
without that demo and without those
choices from management
and without showing people what they
think it could be they missed the mark
they made mistakes right and then they
made mistakes
on top of mistakes heading into the
heading into the winter
but from the business side of things the
developers complaining about that
initiative in particular right perhaps
the most successful hype cycle in the
last 20 years
they're wrong right well that literally
that's what the studio had came back and
fired back at jason with that he said
because pretty much he's basically said
that vertical slice is a common
you know thing he even yeah he even
fired back but i'm glad to be backed up
i haven't seen this i'm blocked from
that thread well if you want if you go
to askowski's
twitter the ceo the studio head uh okay
cd projekt red his is up there
and he has that but i'll get it to you
if you still need it but um yeah pretty
much you just say like it's hard for a
trey show to be a test division of
vertical slice it doesn't mean it's fake
compared to demo with the game he goes
in depth with that he's he he
doubles down he said if you look at that
demo now it's different yes but that's
what the work in progress
watermark was for he said our final game
looks and plays way better than that was
and the other point of contention is he
said
that um when jason said most of the
staff knew and openly said it wasn't
wouldn't be ready for release of 2020
he said you'd only talk to 20 people
some being ex-employees
only one of which is not anonymous i
wouldn't call that
most of the over 500 people staff openly
said what you claim
now in jace's defense he did not answer
all the other allegations that jason had
to get to the studio and and what was
reported but look hulk this is all you
the whole apology what i saw your video
so that's your thoughts and then the
article slash
exposed by jason yeah so i i looked at
the apology i analyzed the apology and
did it basically
uh section by section in virtual
legality we did our you know
different colored slides and things like
that um you know the one thing i will
say
on it is the aspect that i didn't really
see covered very much outside of my
channel
is that cdpr is currently being sued by
its investors
more specifically it's american
investors yes um and so there are a lot
of
sentences that you can see in that
statement
that are designed somewhat ironically to
effectively say
there was no plan to commit fraud we're
too incompetent
stupid to do that and if you and that's
not that's not to say that they actually
are
that's what the message of the statement
is we just didn't know what we didn't
know we screwed up we got this timing
wrong
oh we truly believed everything was fine
because the
the lawsuit against them is premised
around them being nefarious mustache
twirling fraud
ah i love that i love the visual exactly
that knew the entire time
that oh sony's going to pull us off the
store but we're going to get them
and we'll cash out before then so
that is the purpose of parts of the
statement
right the rest of the statement is uh
pull the other one in terms of what
they're saying so we didn't know the
playstation
it was fine we thought it was fine the
testers didn't show up anything
absolutely and oh by the way the city is
just
gorgeous isn't it how about those pc
players pc game they were very strong on
the pc
we sacrificed all for the pc we couldn't
make such a beautiful gem the likes of
which nobody has ever seen if we didn't
throw those console peasants
under the mighty pc bus you know you
know it's crazy uh
cd's done something i haven't seen too
many people have to do
get dreamcast guy go live
true it's true mm-hmm and and that and
that's the statement and i think it's
better i want to be honest
okay so there's my tilt here which i put
in my own videos loved witcher 3
have loved what cd projekt red has been
putting together for a decade
um was very or or more really was
surprised at how this all turned out was
very critical of them
in the fall and in the winter saying you
guys need to stop talking you're making
it much much
worse and you're throwing people
everywhere under the bus sony microsoft
your testers
stop and then they get sued by their
investors and then this statement comes
out
and i think a lot of people reacted to
it negatively i certainly pulled out
some of the aspects that i thought were
untruthful or at least close to the line
and the question is why did they make
the statement and i would guess
from the timing now is that they knew
that the schreyer article was coming out
that's what schroeder said in reference
to adam's response just now
they wanted to put it out in front of it
which you put all this timing together
you get that kind of
you get that kind of notion the the
shreyer article
you know i read through and and like i
said some people criticize me on twitter
say well it's just so broken nothing
seems new because i looked at it and
said
it's pretty hollow i mean the one thing
i always recommend to people to do
is to try to think about the other cases
which is that
you know how often do the things that
trier finds in a given company apply to
every company and every
industry and everything that is putting
out a product into the world and
and you know one of the things i often
say is developers the creatives the
people making the thing
will always want more time there's
there's no question things don't get
finished they get released to the wild
right and a lot of times you can land
that plane
you know bioware landed that plane seven
times in a row before they
really really failed to land a couple
planes right
and you get that from all these things
and that's what cd projekt red has done
he frames it as well we did the witcher
it'll work out right to some extent
you are doing that in every management
team in every project
software and video games is hard it's a
creative endeavor you're doing 25 new
things a day
and so i thought some of the framing
there was
tilted um and i think i think jason does
this he gets the voices and he does this
well and i like that there's an
investigative person in video gaming
period
but i think that has jaded him to some
extent to hearing only
everything is on fire all the time okay
um and so i look at it and i've worked
with a lot of people a lot of
well-intentioned people well-meaning
people see
project red is huge and should maybe be
doing this better than smaller
developers
but right everything i heard in that
article oh they said
april 2020 and we and the one that he
uses is kind of a damning silver bullet
at the end of one paragraph is
and i thought it'd be lucky if we got it
out in 2022 or whatever
and that's at the time that that
announcement is made and you look at
that
and that becomes the headline on ign the
developers knew it wouldn't be ready in
2020 i'm like
screw you ign that is that is ridiculous
framing
of that kind of quote because what it is
is oh my god there's no way my
management is stupid which if anybody
has ever worked anywhere in the world
has thought one time or another
right and that might mean the management
is stupid and certainly they made
mistakes and didn't release a product
that seems to have crossed the finish
line as we would all hoped
right might just mean that they're
pressing hard and they think we can get
it done and we can get it done and
and maybe you that is the concept artist
or the level designer or the trigger
pressure guy on the gun play
can't see the whole picture and i can
always find a guy
i could always find a guy for the most
popular games i keep using last of us
because it came in hot but at one game
of the year and a lot of people love it
right and you're comparing last of us to
cd projekt red
cyberpunk 2077. i know i know cyberpunk
you're not doing that i don't mean to
compare them like
okay to defend hogue i see what you're
saying is that they're both games that
had
their own style of controversy and a lot
of crunch a lot of very
vocal crunch but the difference was a
finalized polished product and a game
that came out
and both of them had the same thing
which is that i got to push back
but but i say this i say this to answer
that part right
because you know i'm going to defend the
game of the year anyway um
which one i say there's
yeah i'm gonna say this to say
different people in charge sony
understands that something's bad sony
will hold back
and and i'm gonna respect sony and that
that was there that's what
that's what i love about sony super
project
red doesn't do that all right and they
haven't done that with the witcher
either
the witcher was a much cleaner landing
than this i agree that its performance
wasn't as good as it became
but that was a much cleaner release than
this one right there i don't think a
much cleaner release hulk
is because the other two was uh abysmal
messes at their launches as well
and the other two launched a witcher one
yeah i mean they didn't have the burden
of
they didn't have that burden of
expectation that cyberpunk had right
which
with the three coming to console was the
first time a witcher game would really
come to console
across the board like we got witcher 2
on the xbox 360 and we got it back and
pat
but those games were pc games and that
and that just didn't
so when the witcher 3 came out yeah it
was it was kind of a trash fire it was
it but but again they were forgiven
because cd projekt red then wasn't what
we know
cd products were to be now they just
didn't have that that sort of
that cache with the consumer so it was
it was always going to happen in that
like regardless of the state that the
game came out and i'm not
you know defending it at all but they
were always going to catch
more heat than they than they did for
the witcher just because their stature
was different
well that most successful hype cycle i
talked about earlier has its benefits
and has its burdens
i mean the hype for this game was insane
right um and so
you're exactly right that was always
going to come back against them
in that capacity of if it's not perfect
if you have anything
a tweet storm of a spinning head just
like bethesda's faced for years and
years and years
and that was in fact the case i mean my
problems with cyberpunk are actually a
little bit more
deeply in the bone which is that they
didn't tell me the stories that i
thought i would get
out of the witcher they didn't really
have the characterizations in the
campaign that i had expected
and so that's different from my car
occasionally floats and explodes the
world which
does happen um so i mean i
i agree completely with what king said
which is that
the right call is to pull it or more
specifically to make it a pc only
release and decide
that's what you do um and it's clear
from the road map that they put in that
apology that in
all reasonable respects we're not going
to get the cyberpunk that we had
expected the next gen game with any
remotely
kind of clean release until the end of
this year
yeah so it's it's like a year or later
so you know they weren't they weren't
coming in hot
they didn't have a runway they didn't
have an island they didn't have any
landing gear
and so they they crashed the plane and
and king is right
that the right call was this doesn't go
out why because that
hurts our brand reputation and our
goodwill and we have to go make up for
it
and ordinarily i would say then that was
the wrong call to release it
right except i don't know what the
refunds look like i don't know what
money they made i don't know how much
people are going to hold it against them
and if they just devote themselves to a
year of fixing it i don't know whether
they effectively get the no man's sky
treatment and everybody's just cool with
it after a little bit of time
i don't know yeah no this is this is
fantastic the last part to say hope
before you leave
as far as the development um you know
we're hearing different
different things you know as far as you
know it's shifting from what is it the
third person to to first person yeah
yeah
and the announcement you know as far as
you know development not really starting
to like 2016 and stuff like that
when it was announced 20 12
2012 yeah so you know
what about the owner's responsibility on
management i i know you're not a fan of
particularly of
jason's article but i meant in reference
to that
level of okay with announcing 2012 then
it doesn't get started till this and
then there's so much switching
do you at least recognize that level of
turmoil being a problem with the owner's
responsibility should be on publishers
management ceo
that kind of thing i think all of their
responsibilities should be on them
certainly and i think
they've made mistakes and they've made a
ton of them and i agree that they
shouldn't have released it in december
as they did
and i don't think that this the things
that they said at the time frame of the
release were sufficient to satisfy their
consumer base and i don't think they
should be satisfied
right um outside of that i think the
only thing that i
impress upon people is that really good
products
had a real high level of tumult you guys
love destiny
bungie has not not landed a hot plane in
their entire
factual that is all they land yes coming
in hot
all day every day that's all they do it
doesn't look like it's gonna work
i can't give away the secret to the game
i can tell you my brother worked
unforsaken i i could things are hot
okay they don't even they don't even
have ac they just board them
that's a great great great developer
right they're a great developer
and so different things work for
different studios and cd projekt red
thought okay we're going to do it like
witcher
and it certainly sounds like that is a
great uh like kind of tidbit from the
stuff that we've been hearing he's like
yeah you would have expected them to
make a third person game that's why when
they put that demo out everybody was
like what
because cyberpunk you know you make a
third person game and then the guy comes
out so adamantly that you don't do gun
play out of first person and he's like i
guess
and it works ish but it's a different
way of making a game
so i i i'm obviously have two minds here
i think
they can get their they can get their
goodwill back but they really burn their
reputation in the ground
um and you're not going to be able to
sell the next game the same way you sold
this game absolutely
a lot of uh friction there now if it
gets those 99
yeah and it's awesome people don't care
yeah and but
yeah i agree i agree that's the thing
before you because i wanted to hit you
with that
yeah which is two points you just made
one
cautionary tale to all other studio
heads
and game publishers right on how to
handle and then two like you said it's
funny because
if they do rebound it game is a forget
quick
the dlc next deal is no
you just don't put it on the commercial
they'll never know no and i agree with
you
completely i mean the big mistake that
they made at the end
was the four release dates yes once you
do that you look incompetent
and you hit december and you're like i
can't do a fifth release date and you go
to that investor call and one of the
things they say is guys we couldn't do a
fifth release date
i mean we can't we couldn't do it and so
once you've locked yourself in
you see some of the responses already
happening here in early 2021 when the wb
says one of their big foundational
titles that hogwarts game is going to
sell a fortune
yep and they say we we don't know not
this year
in the key is this in
definitely it's okay right it's not this
year
exactly that's where they messed up once
you have the third delay it's okay to
say fam
indefinitely but when when the ballroom
got that reputation
they're worrying about the quarterly
financials over what
actually could be produced i'm sure
their cash position was stressed exactly
i'm sure it was
but you go to a bank and you say we got
this thing finished we just need another
year i mean
you're going to sell 13 million copies
in a weekend you can go get a loan
so you know i i i hear what everybody is
saying
i am obviously uh upset with some of the
things that they have done and how
they've treated people i think they're
on the
right course and then we can get down to
the nitty-gritty of cyberpunk not being
anywhere remotely as good as the witcher
thank you for your time brother i know
you guys yeah i apologize i have to go
thank you so much for having me yeah
brother thank you
always a pleasure man hold on business
law firm the
legend of virtual legality and lord
king's affectionate
uh wet blanket oh god
i love i love vogue for actually
grounding people and you know keeping
your uh your stuff in perspective
he's only touching he can't ground us
that's the only thing
you don't have to hear the truth but
he's gonna give you the truth
i have my opinions they're strong it is
what it is i love you guys thank you for
having me brother have a good one man
enjoy your sunday brother always a
pleasure always a pleasure solving super
chat to just move on with uh drink has
got everybody else thoughts and then we
get out of here
actually we just got uh john millich
with the five dollar super chat awesome
show as always great guests this week
thank you thank you anybody else nope
that's it
dreamcast guys you went live you had a
lot to say
i was what's funny is
yeah i mean so just just to look at the
situation i mean i've put so many hours
into this game i've gone back and forth
about loving the story and hating the
glitches and thinking it's so good on my
xbox series x
and it crashes on my playstation 5 and
it looks like garbage on my roommate's
old school vcr xbox one
i mean it's it's such an erratic game
but this statement
i was much more a fan of the jason
schreyer article because
it gave us our first concrete window
into this project and the big thing i
feel like a lot of people kind of
overlooked is the fact that cd projekt
red
wanted this game to be the best game
ever like that was their goal was to try
and make this the best game ever
but management released it unfinished
and honestly i made a video reading
every single freaking word of the
article that jason schreiber put out
because i think he explained so many
good points
as to the fact that like people were
just
kind of stuck in this huge multi-hydra
team of like all right art's over here
audio's over here
here's uh the voice acting people the
writing team are trying to
finish writing quests when they don't
even know what guns you're gonna have
like
i i honestly i i sympathize so much with
the developers but
me too that fake demo that was the thing
that stuck with me the most and the
reason why
is because we do realize that everything
is a bit of a puppet show right like
we've
all been in the gaming industry we've
all watched so many e3s we realized that
to some degree
this is a play right there are actors
that are coming out and pretending to
play the finalized game
we understand that but this was the
first time where what we saw
wasn't the game none of that code that
wasn't even in the game yeah
yeah not none of that art like so much
of that stuff was not in the game
and so i think we just have to realize
that as weird as as much as it sucks i
think that this is
gonna be an educational moment for a lot
of us of you can get excited for a game
hype is absolutely the best part of a
game sometimes is that excitement before
you get a chance to play it we just have
to realize now of like all right these
people are
to some degree bsing us because
pre-orders matter
and that sucks but i think that that's
that can also be healthy
no he make a valid point i mean
literally king has been on that i know
he's been on that school he's gonna
chop out the big i gotta get the super
chat solved that addict
hold on we got jd gamer i think before
jd we may have missed one two
no we got john miller in there we got
him okay cool so i'll make sure okay oh
we got jd gaming with the
will publishers really learn not to
release early there was uh
andromeda anthem cyberpunk sod three
s-s-o-t
what was s-o-t of thieves yeah days gone
uh only nintendo seems to avoid this um
jd gamer again with the 5
super chat there was a quote from
platinum games that made me look at how
the
the different platform holders handled
game development be it microsoft
nintendo or playstation
[Music]
they said they'd learned yeah five
dollar sweet chat again from jd gamer
they said they'd learned a lot about
game development and quality control
uh since not hands-off but uh but not
micromanaging so neither sony nor
microsoft got the praise
gotcha i think the big problem is that
these the game console people like if
it's being published if it's a microsoft
game or an ea game or a playstation
studio project the big problem is that
eventually
a lot of these people are slaves to
investors and i hate to say that because
it sort of demeans art
i think people kind of forget the fact
that as much as we respect these games
they are
like old white dudes and suits who have
never played anything but candy crush
at the end of the day they kind of press
the launch button sometimes
and so even sometimes people are putting
out games that sometimes they don't want
i've had a chance to sit down and have
private conversations with people
sometimes and
uh like i won't say his name but i
talked to somebody that worked on do
maternal
uh and i talked to him before they
delayed it and he was telling me
straight up that the game was super
ready to go
um and they decided to delay it because
they realized okay this game right now
is a nine out of ten but if we push it
into march this will be a 10 out of 10.
and so i think
these big freaking publishers sometimes
they just say
well we already have 10 million dollars
of pre-orders and that's not that's the
entire budget
just put it out like just fix it later
apology and the whole um jesus right
article
what's your feelings on stuff i saw i
didn't catch up on everything about the
um
the jason uh article i did catch up a
couple things where
like apparently the whole game was
supposed to be third person and that's
why some of the features were removed
like
the climbing walls and stuff with that
that's kind of weird
uh apparently it was like the older gen
consoles couldn't handle it or something
i don't know i didn't read the whole
thing i should have
but uh you know i think when it comes to
this you know i've been
you guys i've been on the on the the
hill
put the fire and i'm still on that hill
i i want
cd projekt red to be because if you can
make cd projekt red and an example of
you can make anyone an example of
so i but at the same time
i can't like a lot of people are trying
to throw this company with like
the activision and yeah the
eas i generally feel like this company
didn't want to do what they did
they got caught in red tape and they did
it
i honestly think they they regret what
they did i don't think they thought it
was going to get this bad
they thought they were going to get this
i beg to differ i thought i think they
thought they were going to get some
some some pushback they were just going
to be able to
they're going to be able to bounce back
in six months and they'll be fine
i don't think they expect you to get
sued i don't think expected playstation
to pull their game
i don't think they expected to the
degree that happened
like i think that if they could they'd
go back and fix it i don't think they
would do it no
i think they would they they cost their
they they're stopped they're stuck
i'm not going to go understand this but
my point
but at the end of the day i'm not
putting the
this company with the eas and the
activities like right there
what what ea
and then they will come out blatantly
and say they didn't mean to do it they
would never do it again
but then you have so the kids that
punches the kid in the face and saying
that no more
i'm letting you talk i'm just adding to
it i'm not gonna let you talk to them
that's right i'm putting salt and pepper
on it baby come on let's get it all i'm
saying
is what they did was slimy but i i won't
i won't put them with an eea i won't put
them with an activation because
to me i feel like they care more about
their brand than
activision i think ea and activision
don't care as long as they can pipe
money down that line
they will do this again and again and
again
i honestly don't think cd project right
i don't think they'll do this again
good at it finish yeah i'm with you i
know i'm rolling with him and i like
rolling with him
with you
which is that they they're more afraid
of the backlash like these big companies
don't because they are a conglomerate
where cd projekt red
is a studio they're technically an indie
studio they're the biggest indie studio
but like
that backlash affects them more
permanently whereas
ea makes a bad game all right we got 600
again didn't they lose like 2.5 billion
dollars and salt
like yeah the value of that like i don't
think they expected this
like they expected some backlash they
expected some some returns they didn't
expect playstation to go nuclear and be
like we were moving all your stuff
they didn't expect uh you know to the
degree with our investors be like we're
gonna sue you like
you lied to us we want our money back
we're going to see they didn't expect
none of this i i honestly think that
they thought they're going to come out
kind of like the witcher did where the
witcher was you know a little bit busted
but they they they knew it was coming in
hot and you know it's like we said
uh you know bungie likes to crash their
ship then they like to cool it down
afterwards
like like when when city project run
landed
there was no ship anymore they didn't
expect that this morning
before i know it's your turn about a
king clearly wants to disagree so
well i love it because i i i agree with
king so i
let me let me add to that that and then
king could finish off because then
i'll jump in and this is why i disagree
with addict and i
kind of agree with king i do i do agree
with addict in that
i don't think the level of backlash that
they got was expected
they knew what they did though and the
fact that it
it could happen again it's just the
reality of game dev
as much as they would want that not to
happen but i tell you any
you know why i believe that because
the because the apology almost felt like
a non-apology and i tell
and and for one big reason they did not
come out
and say and admit we knew what was wrong
yeah that is true that part is true and
we sent it out
anyway what they said was
we knew what was wrong we
hoped our day one patch would fix it
but we did not know the people
in charge of the game we did not know
that it would still be that bad when it
launched
how do you not know that then he
proceeded then he proceeded
then he proceeded to sort of blame it on
uh
and a qa catching it i wasn't
i wasn't talking about from like a
technical standpoint i was talking about
the backlash
i they knew that this game was coming
out busted that's why they had withheld
the whole last year and i agree with you
i believe that the level of backlash if
you go by
what they went through with the witcher
because they got plenty of black
backlash
with the witcher and but again it would
it was it was stupid on their part to
think that
because because of how their name had
risen since the witcher
like you knew they knew they were going
to be held to a higher standard
and maybe they didn't know they didn't
think sony was just going to drop the
game off the off the
off of the uh the store the digital
games from whatever all that stuff maybe
they didn't realize
that was coming but they knew backlash
was coming and you just didn't know how
much
of it right but it goes back to the idea
of
when you make this apology then at that
point be very clear that
this is a hundred percent our fault and
this is why it's our fault but they
can't because the lawsuit
yeah and that's the thing because they
would they would incriminate themselves
a hundred percent
and but at the same time shut up then
shut up and defend yourself in court and
then and then come out with the with the
real maricopa afterwards
trying to be as transparent as possible
but they couldn't because jason is uh
so they would have had to answer that
thank you they would have handled it
this is why they are slimy yeah so it's
like
they're getting beat up from both sides
and it's their fault they're getting
beat up from both sides and again
i i always want to reiterate this is not
on the devs
when you give the people that make the
art fact
the people that make the art when you if
you were to get them all in the room and
tell and
and ask them when when is this game
ready to come out
this game is never ready to come out i
will work on it so that my dying day
there's something i can add to this game
that is the truth so you know to
contextualize that let's just say okay
i would say 95 of them would say we
needed another year
100 100 percent to make a game that was
at least polished enough and
complete enough where this would not
happen and that and again
that and i've said this a million times
don't
it's impossible to do it but when you
don't divorce the money from the art
facts
this is what happens this is what
happens this is the board room versus
developer
this is what happens and then king got
to go from here yeah
what happened with cd projekt red is
like
one of those things that changes i
honestly think this is going to be
ripple effects it would be a domino
effect
and it's going to go through the whole
industry like this this is
a teaching moment this is probably one
of the biggest things that's happening
in the industry and probably
this entire generation three four three
is like yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah they don't forgot about us
see that's that's exactly my point let's
let's get these super chats okay
because we got to do this hot chip
challenge for those people that stuck
okay so yeah we have the rubber
i got your text message i hit you right
back morning lords my bushes start
shaking when cyberpunk is mentioned
it's like something from a horrible way
and we got jd gamer once again with the
father super chat we should be able to
judge games on if they are
fun or not and do not look good was it
accessible
not if it it freaking works uh save
save corruptions are not fun hold on i
need my old man glasses
i'm getting blurry right now you're good
so that was that
uh and i think we're good on super chats
yeah you got that okay cool
i'm actually i'm actually going to run i
have not eaten today no please brother
please i'm starving absolute pleasure
thank you for rocking out as long as you
ask me we kept you hostage right thank
you dreamers
so fun thank you all so much for having
me this has been such a blast
i love y'all because y'all are such a
wide range like y'all y'all have that
best friend vibe which is very rare
podcast i think a lot of podcasts kind
of have that
we are professionals at a round table i
love y'all's best friend vibe
and also i love that y'all have such
different viewpoints like honestly that
addict and king argument that was
awesome so much man thank you so much
for coming enjoy your day brother have a
go yeah let me let me read jd's once
again because i mangled that button oh
there it is
there's a question
we have jd gamer once again we should be
able to judge games on if they're fun or
not
do not do they look good was it
accessible
or not uh if it freaking works safe
corruptions are not fun
um yeah i mean i guess the the level of
broken that this game has been for a lot
of people
and i guess it's important people uh
idea fun is subjective so you know
some people may say that graphics
looking like doodle is not fun
yeah i mean obviously your game freezing
and start you having to start over
multiple times
they're gonna get this work objectively
not fun so let's go yeah
all right so first of all uh what is it
what was it 2012 they talked
about it and then 2016 they showed this
video
from the moment that you showed that
video it was like 50 minutes long
from the moment they showed this video
they already knew that they was
committing fraud
from the second they hit they hit that
button this hit play and they said work
in progress and
okay so what you what you say before the
start
this is not representative of exactly
what we're doing this
is a projection and we're trying to
reach that but you're not going to do
that because you're used to doing
old business that's old business we're
so used to old business on this podcast
that we've seen it before
so we recognize it but the new guys
don't know old business
so they look at it and when i say old
business i'm gonna give you a for
instance i know you always like to say
i'm going in on sony but
uh final fantasy right not the same
thing that you got
when we got in the house we've been
looking for that ballroom dance follower
how about that oh yeah that old exactly
um uh uh what is it 3do with the m2
i still haven't saw anything that looked
as good as that to this
okay yeah you remember d what was it the
d3
d3 oh my god yo it had ray tracing back
then
it was crazy 3do had ray tracing back
i saw that i was like oh hell no
so they knew that they was committing
fraud then
right now when they said uh
we felt it would be like the witcher uh
you know three
exactly they already bamboozled you the
first time
they already smacked you in the face the
first time and you accepted and you went
on with it and the reason why they got
so much praise is because they gave you
free dlc
they gave you free dlc while they was
fixing it keeping going keeping going
we're fixing it we're keeping going
we're trucking on
all right so they built up all this
great status like sovereign said
the company has risen their status is
totally different now
they're looked at as a a triple a studio
you know what's fine about the public i
don't think they care
you know what's funny king is like they
did so much with the witcher in terms of
like the product that they delivered
that people were con
they were considering them i'm like
naughty dog level oh yeah yes oh and i
get i give props to bt
bg from the beginning was like no yeah
yeah
yeah out here yeah capping too hard they
made
one big game and then and and
and it turned out to be true it's like
they they they drank a little bit
much of their own kool-aid and and when
it came down to it they were not
prepared
they were prepared to do exactly what
they did i'm not letting them off the
hook
let me tell you something you had all
these checkpoints and this was your
conscious talking
the first time you delayed it this was
your conscious talking the second time
you delayed it
it was your conscious talking the third
time you delayed it you should have been
indefinite
you know and i keeping i'm keeping the
same energy the same energy i kept with
microsoft
now i know didn't know anything about
craig to me i thought the game looked
good
the game didn't look like this game
right right you're sitting here talking
like
you know you you did you see this game
listen
how many craig faces is out there well i
tell you when
when you remember the interview i did
with cog yeah
at e3 after he had gotten to see it and
cog was like i this doesn't seem like
i i can't believe this is true yeah
right yeah i got a lot to say
get to that point but this is what i'm
trying to tell you guys
they built up this world now this is the
perfect storm
they this doesn't happen if covet
doesn't happen
everybody's anticipating this yeah
everybody's sitting there with baited
heart like we
need something to play and this this is
it this is the driving force
all your pre-orders did this oh
the board saw it like yo 8 million
already okay we can do this how fast i
can get this game out
or we're not ready yet we're not ready
yet
for fourth time you're not ready yet bro
like this got to come out this year
because i got this yacht
and i'm going to
and you know the situations and you know
everybody on the board like dudes don't
even play games is on the board like you
know that game got to go out can't you
fix it later
like you did the witcher like with the
money that we gave you the last time
you do what like you did the last time
you could always rebuild your reputation
and it was like but we you know just one
more year one more year
they're not trying to hear that when i
got to pay this mortgage on this boat
and stuff
no no no no no this game got to come out
now okay well what about the playstation
base and the xbox uh one the first one
what about that what about what about
them dudes
yeah we worrying about that pc show it
on the best light and don't show it no
place else
oh put it out there so you're committing
fraud straight from the rip you know
better than ea and everybody else
but the only reason why ea can eat that
is like sovereign and addicts said they
have other ips that they can just flow
off
this is an independent yeah maybe the
greatest independent that we got going
now
and when you are beholden like a
sovereign set to the bag
when the bag man is on your head and
telling you
uh well your artistry is very nice my
man but um
i got this car note so get this game out
you knew from the rip that you was
committing fraud
you can't say anything because of the
lawsuits
i respect that part you trying to say
anything
you know sovereign wants you to shut up
shutting up right now gets you in
trouble
sony at that time the reason why sony
yanked it
sony at that time was having their own
little issues right
they don't need that pile on they said
no no no no we this is not even of our
own volition
we don't need that over here bro you
promised something else you got the goal
because they go in and they tell them
yeah if you need a refund just talk to
these guys
so this is this is what happens
there's a perfect storm for them how
they avoided
all of this was putting it off until
next year
now i did not buy said game
i feel you because the game didn't come
out yet
it comes out when that next generation
patch comes out for the game
yeah uh yeah winter 2022 yeah so that's
when it comes out it comes out next year
when it was supposed to come out when
everything was ready
i never trusted them i never trusted
them
and never trusted them because of the
witcher
like you guys forget and you have this
this this this
or the goldfish memory i remember the
dude that smacked me
i remember all the clothes that he had
on i remember if his hoodie was folded
i remember every last thing i was trying
to forget
so the witches smacked me and i learned
from the beginning don't trust those
dudes because they do lie and they try
to fix it up later they beat you up
and they buy you candy i'm not about
these dudes
and they beat you guys up so bad this
time that you was in the hospital
and candy's not fixing it so you guys
got to really
step up with your money it's your it's
your purchasing power
that is dictating if this game comes out
enough
and the broad rules stay with it and the
bonus they win and i tell you this
it's to something getting more
something that hogue said i think at the
end of the day with everything when the
smoke clears
i when the conversations really start to
happen about
whether this game is as good or better
than the witcher
yeah and a lot of the consensus is no
right
that's when like that be beyond this
stuff because every
gamers have short memories right well
when it comes to the quality of the game
oh yeah that that's what you do remember
that's what you do remember yeah
absolutely
absolutely so i i feel it's not it's not
going to bode well because at the end of
the day like when
like alex said like they wanted this to
be the biggest game ever
at the end of the day if you didn't even
hit it hit the landing from a technical
standpoint
and once that that's resolved and the
game doesn't hold up to your previous
game
yeah and that's because coke mentioned
something about the stories
that's what allowed me when the witcher
was broken in the beginning right that's
what made me say
all right but i've never seen side
stories like this i've never seen
detail in in in in side characters like
this in an rpg
and that's what kept me going until they
fixed it
apparently this is not the case with
this game they they've this is not what
this game is it's not even a building
upon
what they what what made that previous
game great
so it's just like oh man they they have
an even bigger uphill battle to fight
they do
they do solve the super chat they don't
want to get by joining them get off uh
we got michael aka bestop's finest for
ten dollar super chat
off topic on tetris effect i got the
very last stage
and let me tell you this game will
stress you out yes you have to break
a hundred lines plus it's at speed eight
i almost broke my premium tv king yeah
that's fracture that's crazy and i think
hold on
i know gamer by choice i think we missed
gaming by choice with the 5 super chat
great show everyone i really enjoyed the
star wars topic i saw the first movies
in the theaters in the 70s
salute to the lords and the guests so
thank you so much thank you yeah man
look y'all said everything
damn man say i'm waiting on 2021 at the
end and
i'm only playing it so i can get the
best representation i want that king
joint
you know i have the game you know i did
get caught up in there the only point i
do want to say though
is um yeah to the demo part you know
solve you were there you interviewed me
after you know the joint and yeah look
we all
we were excited like excited about it
yeah he was i was hype you know what i
what i saw was
was definitely next level so for me look
we all know
the the the game right we all know the
the vertical slice stuff you know i'm
saying but when you read about how much
how many systems and stuff that's caught
that'd been cut out and all that stuff
it does run me the wrong way we got
articlesgaming.net with this stuff we
you know i was promoted like yo what i
saw
was really revolutionary so that part is
sad
and then the last thing is um as far as
what you call it the um
the financial result stuff you know what
i'm saying like at the end of the day
again board room winning you know what
i'm saying and and this
is this should be that cautionary tale
you can't fall into that trap like king
said
if it's the third delay that should tell
you at that point
now you risk your reputation permanently
you know what i'm saying and that's the
thing there's so long if they waited for
you that long
they're gonna wait for you until it
comes down and and another thing like
when that demo that you saw [ __ ] like
when you see most vertical slices right
it's a couple of minutes
it's 45 minutes of gameplay so it's like
this is the game like you gotta be
confident that's what got me
right gotta be tight with old boys that
they got me in there 45 minutes look
crazy we giving feedback
and then he gonna make the statement
that the game
now looked better did the dicks
[Laughter]
fable yeah
it might be the next gen dlc patch that
come out that's when it looked better
see gabe is still going by he said i
just sold three copies of cyberpunk
today
there's a larger number of people that
don't care most of them have just said
they like what they've seen from friends
that play the game
that's what i'm trying to say the
ballroom's still going when the yacht's
still going down it's sad
the sad part about it is like the game's
good
got this pocky joint but i know we had
the last time are we okay today
let's let's drop that topic yeah because
i'm trying to get up my stopwatch on my
phone
all right no doubt this is the pocky
time
i'm gonna make one we're doing it live
here
but all the topics can i don't know how
zoom work can you
highlight king's camera on here that's a
good question
because it's i don't know how that's
gonna work maybe if we
like we're gonna have to mute our mics
maybe if he talks
well i'm just saying like we have to
mute our mic this is the part where the
jewelry comes off
well let's see i'm talking now look like
yeah yeah it's not switching to be so
like i think we're good i think
y'all i don't know you saw the part
where did you let me press yourself
because i double clicked them i think
that might work no
it's it's switching online switching
yeah it might not be switching on your
end though because you're the one doing
it
right right yeah yeah it does it doesn't
okay
yeah it's okay okay get ready y'all it's
that time
this is the time are we muted or not
muted
yeah i double click them so right now
it's it's all freezing on him
yeah this is it right now the oh the
jewel
house is coming up go go
go ahead and take off the overlay so we
can see this gun
he said take off the bottom joint yeah
just know just take off the overlay in
general just don't
let it zoom oh i think we can find it
all right you just have to hit the
hardware yeah
man i don't like the jewels coming off
it reminds me of lucky at the end of
donnie brosco
let me tweet this let me tweet this let
me tweet this
everyone in the chat tweet that
better tweet it out you better um this
is the gloves
you better share it out
and and like yo hit all your playstation
dudes up right now
all the playstation dudes that don't
like me hit him up and tell him right
now
you're about to get his comeuppance
where's wilmy when he wasn't in the chat
i'm tagging him zac will be
telling you
this is this is what i'll be
you know drinking organics okay you know
my my favorite my favorite my hockey
juice
and then you know water oh
man here we go all right all right all
right
see sealed sealed yes sir
yeah you got to tweet out so i can
retweet it yeah yeah yeah yeah tweezers
all right everyone in the chat go to
this tweet
retweet this it says uh everyone in that
chat man reach out
to that we got to get versus the reaper
what is expected
a spicy punch to the tongue king king
can't
i don't drink milk yeah king can't drink
man so this this
is what comes inside of it is nice
there's a little jungle just you know
set you up for the
death let's just
okay that's about it on there um the
chip is in here
all right uh it says uh real peppers
real heat 20 20 they give you a whole
this is the joint if you want to get
down with the picante junk
yo this is
so the brothers got the reaper with the
boxing gloves so they give them
oh they got the [ __ ] like yo
yo yo yo king you ready for the reaper
my guy
all right so what i'm going to do is uh
i can't do it like that
so uh let me get these two attached to
the not let you get rid of the uh
overlapping
you know no yeah because i want to cut
this and put it separately
on you two it's nice there we
that that's that's the bad one oh no
there's one before that no that's that's
the new one
that's that's that's huddy off brother
get that hoodie
off man let me we got
the living flame two dollar super chat
king i can't look stay strong
he said i can't look there we go mariano
pom pom po fighters
right now right now that joint hot as
hell
did you put the stop light on oh man
five minutes five minutes yeah that
joint hard as hell
telling you right now he started 54 i
got up too
we got night music with the 500 critical
you're
[Applause]
like it's the hottest ever like it's
like a jalapeno
get the water ready though just so you
don't say
[Laughter]
whoa jesus
[Laughter]
oh god that droid looked crazy
we got spartan ghosts with the two
possible chat jim ryan getting revenge
for all the ps5 shakes
you know there's going to be two spices
this week for iop
oh my god
is it more on your tongue or is it your
throat
we might break some rules we might break
some rules on the lawyers
look the way it's designed it gets worse
as the fight as it goes
all right so the first break of water is
actually cooling off oh okay okay
i love you but you deserve this picture
you can see himself again
i've seen a lot of people do this
ah we got pixelated g two dollar super
chat you can see him losing xp
yo smitty smith said why clem john
someone called
why do i do it
it's going down my man is this the kick
for a reason you kick for a reason
let's go control three minutes
look at forte he said waiting for the
sweat he's already sweating he already
sweat but he's three minutes
in with this game first of all i sweat
like patrick hewitt anyway
so all that other stuff that you're
worrying about i already told you what
hell i am that shirt that the purple
shirt let's go we got we got wander and
dutch five pound super chat
to buy some cold liquid for your mouth
let's go
let's go squirrely dan two dollars super
jack got
let's go yeah we're still 257 okay let's
go
let's go let's
help you maybe honey since you can't do
milk this twenty dollars
got something for that don't even worry
about that i'm telling you right now
we're raiding right after that
no you're not gonna do that you're gonna
go through the rain
right now your lips get crazy your
throat is nuts one thing you don't want
to do is swallow it that's it
it's in the back it's in your ears
because then it'll be your eyes
it's all over but it's doing this thing
let's go better have a second wave
is what it is it better have a second
weight
if i wasn't so bad with like heat should
i do it too
it better have a second weight
you don't know who the hell i am i'm
that dude
said i hope these ain't king's last word
push through king push through canada
can't stop you
it better have a second wave it better
have a second weight
we got right now super jack king
got all these napkins by his desk for
all that sweat that's about to happen
though it better be a second white
pixel videos ain't talking gully real
good gully
that's the quote you better retweet this
and show this to you
always retweet your fuzzy said it's
weird
[Laughter]
that's what i told you
this is where you'll be hoping wishing
and praying
hoping wishing and praying keep talking
no spicy
let's go let's go tell me five minutes
you started at 350 yeah he's he's there
let's let's go you thought it was going
to be something
you might say that's not a real chip it
was a hell of a real chip
it was definitely in the building but he
can't spar with the king the guard is
crazy
who the hell i was and i'm going to do
some rage right after this
let's go for the said i see you playing
for take back today
here we go i told you forte you're going
to tell the legend of king david
you're going to be talking about me
forever any one of you podcasting dudes
that'd be out there oh you know
i don't think he's a real dude i'm a
realist dude on the way [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
get him let's go get him let's go
and i ain't drinking nothing i got my
roots my drinks
all you dudes is bunnies
i told you who the hell i am don't play
with me
i don't even got a drink like that come
on now you're in your bag brother you're
your bag
i got to give it to you i got to give it
to you you did that
i told you you would be fine he did that
he got philly eagle five dollar super
chat
the second wave is on the exit
we got stitch with the two dollar super
chat i think king ain't a piece of lava
now i'm gonna tell you right now my lips
are still burning
that's what it do but it's not stronger
than me
mentally i'm crazy and then once the
worst thing they could have did
was put a boxing glove dude in here you
have to put the speaker view
so once once once once i saw this
and it was challenging me to a fight oh
man
we got squirrely dead two dollars we
checked king be like yeah
the champion like the top left it'll be
like
unpin him or something like that on the
top left of this thing oh yeah that's
why he's pinned
there we go thank you okay
yeah you got rubber knob with the five
dollar super chat
just wait app
told me that he he he's regularly eating
hot stuff i know you would be
like the the thing that hits people is
when they don't be
getting hot stuff at all
going down like that joy they blow up
your throat let me tell you
like it hit kids smooth so hard king
that he he literally like a little mouse
pad
so your lips is numb my lips my lips
right now now it's not dead though
my lips feel like you know like like a
little burn like
it's like so what's the what was the
worst part
oh when they hit that weight like it was
one part where
i swallowed an old boy was like what's
it's like up now this is what i'm
talking about i got you exactly where i
want you i was like come on man
spin off the ropes throw the jab it's
impossible
for me man just back it up a little bit
all i did
was i had to breathe that's all i did
had the focus and all i had was you guys
see now let me tell you something but
they giving it up right now he giving up
remember
we had in the party chat yes yes the
strength
of every supporter every dude that was
cheering me on
i was never gonna let you down
absolutely not one point
and all those haters that were sitting
there like yeah we got it well they
tuned in
like oh kick him out let's go tcl
playstation game was like yeah
oh and and just to clarify this
wednesday me and king will be playing
that madame edem
whatever it is we're going to be yeah
madonna we're going to be co-opting that
so
definitely tune in to that we're going
to be on the the iop twitch channel
absolutely absolutely i'll i'll think
about it man i might do the once you're
challenged too i'll tell you
oh you're only doing the one-chip
challenge
yeah no money no no you guys are
reflecting let me tell you something
with him right now if
william put up no bread i'm not doing
this
shout out the movie with the sponsor
what's up go go ahead and put up the
exact same thing he had
but put it for me oh yeah and if someone
does it i'll do it i'll do it i'll die
oh cause i can't take heat like you can
but i'll try it why even bother
don't do that that's preserved
you know what he did listen i'm not
dying
you know what he did he saw me and he
got straight from belief
i cracked the lemon water open and this
is all i drink from it mm-hmm
and then all i did was just i drank some
of my my what you would call it
i drank some of this and this was only
for flavor like i wanted some flavor
in my pores ice cream
and if it does i'll do it live just like
you do you know
king absorb the energies of his fan like
goku with the spirit ball
we gotta get about it we got the medic
with the five dollars if we chat yeah
they know spice immunity is a game pass
ultimate exclusive fee
king out here being an advertisement
there we go
yeah forte with the five dollar super
chat i was talking mad stuff glad i was
wrong bro you the real mvp
you better than me the next beer is on
me i'll run you through a raid any time
factual faction
oh we got jw good yeah we got black
ronin with the five law super chat king
talking to exhaust all the heat props
so he's talking to get it out of his
mouth
jw is a still five dollar super chat we
have to get king to try some african
pepper next i enjoy very hot stuff as
well
uh you know we should do
i eat scotch man we should we should uh
we should get cog needle to do oh no
okay first of all first of all let me
make this clear to everybody that's
watching
i'm gonna make this 100 clear to you
guys it's watching
this ain't no joint we gonna pop a chip
for you
all right so you become a patreon and
you go to that patreon tear
and you hit that tip now when you see
that tear and you're gonna see that
price on that tail you're gonna be like
oh i'm not gonna do that
okay then just so calm down pump the
brakes on we're gonna get attic to jump
out the window
calm down pump the brakes sovereign said
he ain't doing it no matter what the
price is
the cog said calm down pump the brakes i
will put another chip challenge up there
again
because i'm gonna tell you right now two
chip i mastered it
oh actually actually there's there's
actually something worse than this oh
yeah it is
they got stuff like that it's called
like the devil's juice or something yeah
you guys
are more fearful for what it might be
and not what you
are i am built forward
tough all right and i'm gonna tell you
right now i grew up in melrose project
a hundred percent this is absolutely
nothing i had no fear in my heart i had
covet
and not diagnosed with it but that's the
only reason why i took this long to get
it done because i would have did it that
same day oh salute the world me hood man
for
putting it up you know you gotta give
him his credit will meet is the man just
little
games behind the box you know what i'm
saying the whole joint you know salute
to y'all salute for y'all
cheering king on so look at the haters
that came to see kicked out i don't like
that
right
i need more people and then michael best
night he said king tugger like he went
up the hot 97 to drop a high 16
by guy holding dell salute kicks they
said he built different k
megan everybody is so in love man that's
what's up man yo
we appreciate y'all without y'all
staying home keep watching
shout out to binky watching talking
about oh 100
shout outs you know salute that's all i
got
anybody got anything else before we rap
out of here this super long crazy show
nah that's it we just leave it on that
just leave it on that we see y'all next
week
actually what was the sad part it wasn't
even that long compared to our own
conversation
i thought it was like a five-hour show
bless up i told you what my opponent do
to you
dad
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you